Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're all ones moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, you're not a Lepopunk champ, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail pitch.
Life was you were seeing, spamming all the time, TOS was no Twitch emo, made you feel, PogChamp, keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes.
Now we're all ones moved on, but I remember Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're all ones moved on, but I remember Twitch chat, all these emotes, PogChamp, Twitch emotes.
Nee, das ist das Java-Emote.
Ja, Leute.
Ende des Jahres, Dezember, da muss ich immer...
Ich muss ja gar keine Steuererklärung im eigentlichen Sinn fertig machen.
Ich muss ja nur alle meine Einnahmen und Ausgaben mal ausdrucken, was nicht schwierig ist.
Einnahmen gibt es über drei verschiedene Sachen, die kann ich ausdrucken.
Und Ausgaben ist, ich gehe mal meine Amazon-Bestellhistorie durch und druck es aus.
So schwer ist das nicht, aber es geht mir trotzdem jedes Mal immer extrem auf den Sack.
Und der Rest macht ja glücklicherweise der Steuerberater, aber trotzdem.
Das ist immer so ätzend.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der das gerne macht, außer Steuerberater?
Und wahrscheinlich macht es ja nicht mal der Steuerberater gerne.
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt niemanden, der das gerne macht.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Niemand macht gerne Steuererklärung.
Naja gut, du musst immer noch die Sachen raussuchen und eingeben.
Und das ist ja das, was mir auf den Keks geht.
Ich mache es ja gar nicht selbst.
Ich mache das ja schon seit Jahren über den Steuerberater.
Ich muss kaum was machen.
Aber das Raussuchen geht mir schon immer so auf den Sack.
Und dann ist immer die Frage, geht mein Drucker noch?
Weil das ist ja immer noch oldschool.
Man muss ja immer noch auf Papier ausdrucken, manche Sachen.
Ich spume.
Wusstet ihr, dass die Corona-Zahlen vom Gesundheitsamt über Fax oder Brief verschickt werden?
Letztens irgendwo gelesen.
Wir kriegen das 2020 nicht.
Wir kriegen das nicht hin, das anderweitig zu kommunizieren.
Wie teuer ist ein Steuerberater?
Also ich bezahle ungefähr 53 Euro für beide Sachen.
Das richtet sich aber auch ein bisschen nach dem, wie viel man da macht.
Also um wie viel Kohle es geht, denke ich mal, dass sich das ein bisschen danach richtet.
Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber so in dem Dreh.
So 53 Euro.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, warum Nike fast keine Steuern zahlt.
Mit einem Steuerberater ist man glücklicher.
Ja, allein schon aus dem Grund.
Wenn das Finanzamt mal irgendwas wissen will, gehen die zu dem und nicht zu einem selbst.
Das ist ja gerade das Gute daran.
Wie gesagt, das Finanzamt wollte jetzt irgendwelche Sachen aus 2015, 2016 von mir haben.
Haben aber an sich einen Steuerberater gewendet, der das denen schickt.
Weil ganz ehrlich, ich würde doch im Leben jetzt nichts mehr von 2015, 2016 finden.
Garantiert niemals.
Deswegen ist gut, dass ich das über einen Steuerberater mache.
Was wollen die uns hier sagen?
10 Gigabit Home.
How to connect.
Ja, einfach anschließen, oder?
Das ist übrigens diesen Switch, den der hier liegen hat.
Das sieht mir aus wie dieser 4-Port MikroTik 10G-Switch.
Den habe ich auch noch hier.
Den wollte ich eigentlich verlosen im Dezember.
Aber viel zu laut.
How to connect.
Ja, dann zeigt man.
What the fuck?
Was ist mit dem?
Das ist aber.
Jetzt kommen wir mit VGA?
What?
Was ist jetzt los?
Ah, okay.
Ah, das können wir uns halt vielleicht trotzdem ganz interessant mal gucken.
Direct Attach Module sind eh das Beste, solange es nicht weit geht.
Da braucht man keine richtigen Module für.
Braucht keine Glasfaserkabel für.
Braucht keine Adapter auf A45-Stecker und gescheite Kabel.
Einfach Direct Attach Kupfer ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Für kurze Strecken ist es billig.
Und nicht schnell.
Was hat VGA jetzt damit zu tun?
Das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Ich scroll noch mal kurz YouTube durch, was die uns wieder empfehlen.
Ich refresh mal kurz.
Aufwachen streamen.
Ja, exzellent.
Ich habe die Cam angelassen.
Sehr gut.
Warum empfiehlt uns das YouTube die ganze Zeit?
Warum?
Das haben wir uns letztens schon dreimal angeguckt.
Aber YouTube ist der Meinung, Max, du musst dir unbedingt Cat-Meow-Saria-Song öfters angucken.
Ist noch zu wenig.
Es hat auch nur.
Es hat auch nur 3,3 Millionen Views.
Monte-House-Tour Teil 3 ist um willst du drauf reacten?
Nee.
Es juckt mich überhaupt nicht, wie das ausschaut.
Okay, das ist im Prinzip immer die gleiche Startseite, aber nichts interessantes drauf.
Aber ich habe schon ein paar Sachen auf.
Aber die YouTube Empfehlung in letzter Zeit sind schon richtig pepega, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Manipulativer Cookie Banner.
Ist das schlimm?
Wer ist das?
Ich kenne den Channel nicht.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kenne ich.
Überhaupt nicht.
Das Funk.
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Man weiß ja nie, man weiß ja nie, ja.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Ich sehe schon, ich sehe schon, immer wenn ich mir die ganzen neuen Channels angucke,
die Zukunft von YouTube Content ist wirklich reacten auf YouTube Content.
So richtig, oder zu aktuellen YouTube Geschehnisse irgendwas sagen.
Das ist schon geil.
Macht Unge noch ein?
Irgendwas anderes außer reacten und alle drei Monate mein Gaming Stream oder so Häuser kaufen.
Ah, exzellent Big Business Stonks.
Ja gut, wenn ich so viel Kohle hätte, würde ich das.
Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was ich gerade sage, weil ich müsste auch endlich mal meine ganze Kohle investieren.
Mache ich aber nicht, weil ich zu faul bin.
Ja, macht's richtig.
Aber wenn du so viel Kohle hast, bist du noch mehr pipiger, wenn du das nicht machst.
Ja, aber der macht das nicht auf YouTube.
Der macht halt was mit Aktien, das ist ja schön und gut.
Aber auf YouTube ist glaube ich nur reaction, oder?
Könnt ihr euch noch an Freiheit für Unge erinnern?
Mit, wie hieß das Netzwerk damals?
War das Mediakraft noch?
Ach, die YouTube Zeit hier.
Alles in MSCI World ETF rein.
Easy.
Zeig mal.
Wir gucken uns jetzt den Stonks, den Stonks-Kurs an.
Achtung.
Chat-Empfehlung.
Und wir wissen ja, auf den Chat kann man sich prinzipiell immer verlassen.
Also Chat sagt, ich soll mir das hier kaufen.
Easy.
Solange man hier nicht...
Hm.
Ja gut, das ist Corona.
Warum geht denn das jetzt nicht weiter runter?
Sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich nochmal abkacken?
Sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich nochmal abkacken, weil jetzt wieder Corona am Start?
Ja gut, das ist Worldwide.
Was interessiert Worldwide Deutschland, ja?
Was ist das hier neben?
Also was ist das?
Bei Prozent können es ja schlecht sein vom Ausgangspunkt.
Was ist das?
Was sind das für Punkte?
Ach, das sind die...
Sind das Euro?
Der Preis von irgendwie so einem Teil, oder?
Also, wie mein Lehrer früher gesagt hat, Zahl ohne Einheit.
Sagt.
Gut, das hat er nicht so gesagt.
Das hat er ein bisschen anders gesagt.
Aber im Prinzip hat er das so gesagt.
Ja, also, weil die Sache ist, die jetzt mal hier liegt im Stream.
Ich habe ungefähr...
Also, nur mal so für das, warum ich mich da echt drum kümmern muss.
Ich habe auf meinem Businesskonto noch ungefähr...
Ich...
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
So irgendwie 70.000 Euro ungefähr.
Und auf dem anderen habe ich...
22.000 Euro.
So, und...
Ich muss den Scheiß unbedingt irgendwie investieren.
Weil ansonsten wird es mit der Zeit einfach weniger.
Und warum sollte ich das...
Warum sollte ich das verschenken, ja?
Das ist doch total pepega.
Warum soll ich das machen?
Ich habe mich da jetzt die letzten 10 Jahre davor gedrückt, quasi.
Mal mich ein bisschen mit...
Mit wie lege ich das Geld an zu beschäftigen.
Crypto.
ETF.
Oh ja, genau.
Das macht tatsächlich der Bitcoin-Kurs so.
Und ich muss mich da...
Ich hasse...
Ich habe es ja schon gesagt.
Ich hasse solche Stonks-Themen, ja.
Aber die Sache ist, die irgendwelche...
Irgendwelche...
Mich irgendwie beraten lassen.
So von irgendwelchen Leuten.
Die, weiß nicht...
Vor allem, die die Provision kriegen.
Will ich nicht.
Excellent.
Oh, Bitcoin-Kurs ist wieder huge.
Massive.
Bit...
Bitcoin-Stonks.
Und...
Ich muss das unbedingt machen, weil ansonsten, wenn ich jetzt einfach noch mal 30 Jahre nix mache oder so,
dann ist das...
So wird das ja immer weniger.
Ich meine, klar, in reinen Zahlen nicht.
Es kommt ja dann was dabei, aber...
Von dem, was ich mir verkaufen kann.
Richtig dämlich.
Ich frage einfach den Chat.
Der Chat, der liegt bei sowas ja nie falsch.
Okay, Chat.
So sieht's aus.
100k in Intel.
Easy.
Na, ich glaube, das ist eines der blödesten Sachen, die man machen kann.
Wirklich alles in eins stecken.
Oder ich lasse mir von KLS die Basics erklären.
Dann kann nämlich...
Da kann nix mehr schief gehen.
How to use better Twitch-TV.
Einfach installieren und benutzen.
Das macht dann nichts mit Wissenschaft drum, ey.
Die Leute haben echt einen Dachschaden.
Okay, ich sehe, dass ich nichts sehe.
So, okay.
Guck mal was.
YouTube.
YouTube-Vorschläge sind massive.
Pepega.
Wir gucken uns jetzt irgendwas...
Wir gucken uns mal das an.
Ich kenne den Channel nicht.
Lass mal gucken.
Lass mal gucken hier.
Ei, ei, ei, ja.
Mix.
So, lass mal gucken.
Was erzählt er uns denn?
Ihre Privatsphäre ist uns wichtig.
Ja, excellent.
Sagen sie alles, sagt Apple auch.
Und Microsoft.
Und überhaupt.
Und eigentlich...
Eigentlich ist es denen allen vollkommen egal, solange sie unser Vertrauen gewinnen
und gut Wetter machen.
Can you fit a whole game in a QR-Code?
Das haben wir schon aus.
Das haben wir uns schon mal...
Das haben wir schon mal angeguckt.
Okay, zeige ich mal her.
Gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile eine...
Gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile eine Browser-Extension,
die einfach immer auf Akzeptieren klickt?
... seit Inkrafttreten der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung im Mai 2018
müssen sich Webseiten vermehrt darum kümmern,
die Einwilligung ihres Klientels einzuholen,
bevor sie diese scheinbar wahllos mit Cookies beballert.
Da seiten mittlerweile nicht mehr einfach so allerlei optionale...
Man muss ja auch dazu sagen, Cookies an sich sind überhaupt nichts Schlimmes, ne?
... setzen dürfen, ist eigentlich etwas sehr, sehr Gutes.
... hatte allerdings die nervige Nebenwirkung,
dass mittlerweile so gut wie jeder erstmalige Seitenbesuch
zunächst von einem riesigen Banner unterbrochen wird.
Ich will nur einmal kurz nachlesen,
wie viele Kalorien noch mal eine Badewanne von Schlagsahne hat.
I don't care about my Cookies.
... muss, bevor ich diese doch eigentlich so winzige Information aber kriege,
entscheiden, welche personenbezogenen Daten von mir erhoben
und in Dritte weitergegeben werden dürfen.
Das ist so ein typisches Beispiel,
diese Auswirkung von diesen Pop-Ups, ne?
Das ist so ein typisches Beispiel von gut gemeint,
aber in der Umgebung nicht so gut gemeint.
... aber in der Umgebung nicht so gut gemeint.
... aber in der Umsetzung irgendwie gefailt.
Letztendlich sorgt es auch dafür,
dass sich keiner mehr damit beschäftigt.
Es drückt doch...
Mal ganz im Ernst, liest das irgendjemand?
Alter, was ist denn hier heute los?
Liest das irgendjemand noch?
Du klickst doch eigentlich immer nur auf eine Sache,
immer das Gleiche.
Du kannst ab und zu mal die Cookies leeren
und dann bist du wieder genauso wie vorher.
Mich jucken Cookies überhaupt nicht.
Das geht mir voll am Arsch vorbei.
In Zweifelsfall, wenn es irgendwelche Sachen gibt,
wo ich nicht wüsste,
wie das wiedererkannt werden will.
Zumindest über Cookies und solche Sachen
mache ich Inkognito-Mode an,
der mich ja auch nicht wirklich inkognito macht.
Oder sollte man besser sagen,
Inkognito.
Die allermeisten Cookie-Banner
nicht gerade einfach, schnell und effektiv zu widersprechen.
Im Gegenteil, sie scheinen sich gegenseitig
immer weiter in Sachen Übersichtlichkeit
und Bedienbarkeit zu unterbieten.
Und das nervt mich.
Sicher nicht nur mich, habe ich mir gedacht.
Also habe ich versucht, mir einen Überblick
über die Methoden manipulativer Interfaces
von Cookie-Bannern und deren Effektivität
zu verschaffen.
Okay, dann zeige ich mal her.
Gute Frage, Fips.
Dann zeige ich ja gleich was zu.
... welche Kriterien ein Cookie-Banner
überhaupt erfüllen muss, um DSGVO-konform zu sein.
Oh, Big Stonks.
Schließlich ist der Reiz an manipulativer Kommunikation
ja nichts Gesetzeswidriges zu tun
und die Kundschaft trotzdem zur Einwilligung
optionaler Cookies zu bringen.
Das wichtigste Kriterium ist hierbei,
dass Cookies, die für die Funktionalität
der Webseite nicht notwendig sind,
also solche, die zählen, wie oft man bereits
die Amazon-Seite der Playstation 5-Aktivität,
aktualisiert hat, nur dann aktiv sein dürfen,
wenn man selbst eingewilligt hat,
dass diese eingesetzt werden dürfen.
Die DSGVO setzt also ein sogenanntes
Opt-in-Verfahren voraus.
Ein ganz gutes Beispiel hierfür
ist der Fall von Planet49,
einer Gewinnspielseite,
die auch vorher nicht gerade durch ihre Seriosität
aufgefallen ist.
Warum eigentlich nicht Planet69?
... der Cookie-Abfrage
bereits alle optionalen Cookies angekreuzt,
sodass der Nutzer jedes dieser Häkchen
wieder wegklicken musste und schlussendlich
allen optionalen Cookies widersprechen zu dürfen.
Ah, yes.
Kein Opt-in, sondern ein Opt-out-Verfahren
und damit eine Verletzung der DSGVO,
wie später der Bundes- und der Europäische Gerichtshof bestätigte.
Grundlegend lässt sich also sagen,
wir als potenzielle Gäste einer Seite
müssen uns für Cookies entscheiden,
damit diese eingesetzt werden dürfen.
Diese Spielregeln mögen zwar gelten,
aber das muss natürlich noch lange nicht heißen,
dass man nicht auf Biegen und Brechen versucht,
trotzdem so viele wie möglich dazu zu bringen,
schnell allem zuzustimmen.
Und hier kommen wir in den Bereich
des sogenannten Nudgings.
Nudging ist ein Oberbegriff für Taktiken,
die genutzt werden, wenn Menschen
eine eigene Entscheidung treffen sollen,
man ihnen aber eine Möglichkeit attraktiver machen will,
als die anderen.
Ah, ah, ah, verstehe.
Wisst ihr, was auch Nudging ist?
Jetzt weiß ich, wie das Wort heißt.
Wenn man sich einen Server
bei 1&1 kaufen will,
jetzt mal unabhängig davon,
warum man das Ganze machen sollte,
aber ich sage,
ähm,
so, und man geht jetzt hier auf,
äh, wo ist denn Hosting?
Ähm, ähm,
Virtual Server Hosting.
Tarif.
Dann geht man auf den Server für 1€ im Monat
und jetzt, und jetzt,
und jetzt wird genatscht gleich.
Hallo?
So, 12 Monate kosten 1€ im Monat.
Ein Monat kostet 1€,
aber 10€ Einrichtungsgebühr.
Also man hat die Auswahl,
11€ für einen Monat
oder 12€ für den Monat.
Also 12 Monate.
Da ist ja wohl ganz klar,
was da probiert wird.
Schon gesehen, dass es ein
Overwatch-Turnier in Korea gerade ist.
Nee, ich verfolge das gar nicht mehr.
... Disziplin geschehen
durch Betonung,
Wortwahl,
Belohnung,
Musik oder
Aufwand und Design.
Die Gestaltung von manipulativen
Benutzeroberflächen,
die Menschen zu einer bestimmten
Entscheidung drängen sollen,
ist in den letzten Jahren
zu einer Art eigenen Kunstform geworden,
die sich Dark Patterns nennt.
Pro.
Ein gutes Beispiel dafür sind die in
Programminstallationen versteckten
optionalen Warenkörner, die...
Was soll das hier?
Warum wird das Dark Patterns genannt?
Ich muss jetzt empört sein.
So geht's aber nicht.
Abmahnung ist raus.
... als Standardsuchmaschine.
Man klickt sich Seite für Seite im Setup weiter
und muss plötzlich höllisch aufpassen,
dass man nicht einfach immer auf dieselbe Stelle klickt,
denn auf einmal sind die Knöpfe weiter
und überschritten.
Wer hat auch schon mal aus Versehen die Ask.com Toolbar installiert?
Oder irgendwie so ein Blödsinn?
... springen vertauscht.
In Bezug auf Cookie-Banner fällt dabei
zunächst das häufige visuelle Ungleichgewicht
zwischen alle akzeptieren und alle ablehnen auf.
Wer, wie ich, schnell eine alltägliche Zahl nachschauen will
und jetzt wirklich gar keine Lust hat,
sich jetzt noch ein Textfeld durchzulesen,
was sich plötzlich in den Vordergrund gestellt hat,
der klickt wahrscheinlich einfach schnell den großen,
meist auch farblich hervorgehobenen Knopf.
Ja, klar.
Das ist das gängigste und wahrscheinlich auch
selbstverständlichste Beispiel manipulativer Kommunikation
in Cookie-Bannern.
Die nächste Stufe fällt dabei meist gar nicht auf,
weil sie schon fast als normal angesehen wird,
aber Cookie-Banner sollten nicht beantwortet werden müssen.
Es gibt genug Beispiele von Cookie-Bannern,
die sich irgendwo abseits des eigentlichen Seiteninhalts auftun
und die Bedienbarkeit der Seite nicht unterbrechen.
Das wäre natürlich gut.
Aber eine HTML-gegossene Gefahrenbremsung
sorgt natürlich für Aufmerksamkeit und den Dreh...
Ja, die Sache ist aber auch die,
ich glaube, das liegt auch noch woanders dran,
dass das viele Seiten bevorzugen,
die wollen quasi auf Nummer sicher gehen.
Nicht, dass sie...
Weil ansonsten muss man das ja bei der Webseite sehen,
bei der Webseitenprogrammierung auch noch beachten,
hat der User zugestimmt, hat der User abgelehnt
oder hat der User vielleicht noch gar nichts gemacht.
Das heißt, da muss man immer drei Fälle abfackeln,
je nachdem, was man machen will.
Deswegen ist es rein aus Entwicklungssicht natürlich viel einfacher.
Man fragt von Anfang an und weiß,
okay, auf jeder weiteren Seite, wo der User hingeht,
ist auf jeden Fall die Frage geklärt
und ich weiß, was ich machen muss.
... am gesuchten Inhalt zu kommen.
Diese Kombination kann man dann auch noch
mit einer geschickten Formulierung servieren.
Statt auf den großen, auffälligen Button
einfach alle akzeptieren zu schreiben,
verwenden andere Seiten viel lieber die Formulierung
weiter mit empfohlenen...
... was den Anschein eines Kompromisses erweckt
und auch noch...
Sehr gute Idee.
... zum Inhalt geht und die Unterbrechung vorbei ist.
Wem das noch nicht reicht,
der kann den Aufwand zum Ablehnen von Cookies
natürlich noch gehörig anschrauben.
Statt den Knopf für alle ablehnen
direkt neben den Knopf für alle akzeptieren zu legen,
wird er sehr häufig auf eine zweite Seite gelegt,
auf die man nur kommt, wenn man...
Settings, ja.
... namens Weitere Optionen anklickt,
die oft in derselben visuellen Gewichtung vorliegt
wie das Impressum oder die Datenschutzerklärung der Seite.
Hier sollten dann alle Häkchen für optionale Cookies
automatisch abgewählt sein,
Seiten wie Twitch machen das aber trotzdem nicht.
Ist man mit seinen Einstellungen zufrieden,
kann man hier dann letztendlich die Einstellung speichern
und endlich fortfahren.
Aber halt, da habt ihr die Rechnung ohne die FAZ gemacht,
denn da und auch bei der Welt und vielen anderen Seiten
ist der Knopf, der visuell darauf hindeutet,
hier alle Änderungen zu bestätigen,
und fortfahren zu können
meist wieder
der Alle akzeptieren Knopf,
der alle eben vorgenommenen Einstellungen ignoriert
und statt dessen jegliche optionalen Cookies nutzt.
Statt dessen ist links daneben...
....
Dazu kann man echt nur noch sagen...
Alternativ kann man auch einfach alle Cookies
immer akzeptieren
und regelmäßig löschen.
Oder eventuell, je nachdem wie hart man drauf ist, direkt löschen, nach Browsersitzung schließen oder Tab schließen oder was auch immer.
Ausgegraut mit schüchternem Blick gen Boden der Knopf, um die eben vorgenommene Auswahl tatsächlich auch zu speichern.
Und die Effektivität dieser persuasiven Designs hat eine Studie im Januar 2020 untersucht,
indem sie die Top 10.000 Seiten des Vereinigten Königreichs unter die Lupe genommen
und unterschiedlich manipulative Designs Testpersonen vorgesetzt hat.
Hier hat das Verlagern der Ablehnfunktion auf eine zweite Seite dazu geführt, dass ca. 23...
Bist du dir eigentlich jetzt mal ernsthaft, ohne Mist, wie aufwendig so ein Video ist?
Sieht nicht aufwendig aus, aber wenn das nur einer macht, bist du Stunden, Tage eventuell damit beschäftigt.
Tage.
Allein schon die ganzen Einblendungen, Overlays, sind ja nicht wirklich krasse Animationen, aber das ist nicht easy.
Das sieht so aus, wie mal in 2-3 Stunden zusammengeklickt.
Nee, nee.
Mehr allen Cookies zugestimmt haben.
Wenn ein Cookie-Banner mehrere Seiten genutzt hat, haben nur knapp 7% der Interaktion auf der zweiten Seite stattgefunden.
Und laut dieser Studie zeigen nur 12,6% der untersuchten Webseiten akzeptieren und ablehnen überhaupt auf derselben Seite.
Es wäre ziemlich naiv zu glauben, diese Situation würde sich einfach so...
...bessern.
Schließlich liegt es im Interesse der Seiten, so viele Tracking-Cookies wie möglich zu platzieren.
Es liegt also mal wieder an uns als User, den Aufwand zu betreiben, unsere Daten zu schützen und...
Gut, ist ja immer so.
Das ist ja immer so.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, du kannst dich einfach nicht drauf verlassen, dass jemand anderes was für dich macht.
Geht einfach nicht.
Das habe ich schon so oft im Stream gesagt.
Und das ist da wieder genau das Gleiche.
Also du musst dich drum kümmern.
Und sei es nur, dass du einen Browser-Add-on installierst, die richtigen Settings in deinem Browser machst oder was auch immer.
Du musst letztendlich selber gucken.
Ja, ist letztendlich wie Season Pass, dann wieder kein Season Pass, dann Microtransactions, dann keine Microtransactions.
Jetzt nennen wir es wieder anders.
Letztendlich geht es immer nur darum, die Leute auszutricksen.
Und warum?
Weil Stonks.
Gemacht ist es nicht getan.
Das alles ist nur temporär und früher oder später findet man sich in einer Situation wieder, in der man unterliegt.
Wie bei einer Badewanne voll Schlagsahne.
Ich habe mir noch nie Gedanken gemacht über eine Badewanne voll Schlagsahne, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ihr schon mal?
Aber sollte man vielleicht mal machen.
Flirtbots auf Instagram.
Tja, alles nur für die Stonks.
Alles nur für die Stonks.
Jetzt wo ich den Typ sehe.
Was ist eigentlich da aus CSU geworden?
CSU.
Wo ist dieser?
Wo gibt's die?
Wo gibt's das?
Wo gibt's das noch?
CSU?
Ich will das nicht gucken, Leute.
Macht euch keine.
Also seid nicht geschockt.
Ich will nur gucken, ob es das noch gibt.
Okay, das gibt's noch.
Das gibt's noch.
Es guckt halt keiner mehr, aber das gibt's noch.
Guck mal, am Anfang haben das total viele geguckt und mittlerweile juckt es keine Sau mehr.
Null.
Die haben sich nicht gelöscht.
Nein.
Nein, die sind noch da.
Aber nicht sonderlich bedeutend, wie es aussieht.
Okay, was können wir uns sonst noch mal angucken?
Also, ich will nur mal kurz hier durchgrillen.
Was wollte der uns sagen mit Netzwerkkabeln?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so interessant.
Also, ich meine, es gibt im Prinzip drei verschiedene, es gibt vier verschiedene Arten, wie man, also grundsätzliche Arten, wie man 10 Gigabit Netzwerk anschließen kann.
Die Oldschool-Variante über ganz normale Kupferkabel, wenn man denn einen Router hat oder einen Switch hat, besser gesagt einen Switch hat.
Der AY-45-Ports mit 10G hat.
Das ist die einfachste Variante.
So.
Als nächstes über solche Module und Glasfaserkabel.
Dann gibt es solche Module auch als Adapter.
Das auf AY-45-Stecker.
Und das letzte und einfachste ist Kupfer-Direct-Attach.
Fertig.
Mal gucken, ob er das noch zeigt.
Das sind Kabels, genau.
Das ist Kupfer-Direct-Attach.
Das ist das Beste, was es gibt, wenn man kurze Strecken 10 Gigabit machen will.
Weil das ist billig und du brauchst...
Du brauchst keine Module, was es noch billiger macht.
Ja, so in irgendeinem...
Direct-Attach-Kabel kostet nichts.
Ja, das...
Muss ja nicht übertragen.
Das ist viel zu teuer.
Kriegst du teilweise für 40 Euro oder so.
Naja, das ist viel zu teuer.
Die Preise kannst du dir jetzt...
Lull weh, ja.
Aber das geht schon eher in die Richtung 40, 50 Euro.
Gut, 2 Meter.
Ich glaube, mehr als 5 Meter geht damit aber nicht.
Maximal.
Ich glaube, maximal 5 Meter.
Eher 2.
So.
Das war's.
Also, Video zusammengefasst.
In 30 Sekunden.
Ach ja, und wer...
Wer...
Einen Switch hat...
Hier, das ist...
Den habe ich auch hier liegen.
Wer einen Switch hat, der nur SFP-Plus-Ports besitzt...
Ähm...
Da gibt es von MikroTik recht günstige...
SFP-Plus auf RJ45-Module.
Sowas da.
Zumindest waren die mal günstig.
Da habe ich mir 3 Stück gekauft damals.
Ähm...
Ja.
Übrigens, der nicht.
Das ist nur SFP.
SFP...
Die gab's doch nicht.
Das ist doch für paar 30 Euro.
Was ist denn hier los?
Warum ist das so teuer mittlerweile?
Ja.
Also, musst du dir überlegen.
Da bezahlt man pro Port nochmal 40 Euro obendrauf.
Das stimmt.
Das ist generell ein Problem, dass die...
Äh...
Dass viele Switches, was Module angeht, ziemlich zu picky sind.
Zum Beispiel...
Ich habe ja diesen...
Ich habe ja das Ding hier als Switch.
Ich habe ja dieses Teil hier als 10G-Switch.
Und...
Die hatten am Anfang richtige Firmware-Probleme.
Dass die...
Die haben am Anfang...
Die haben am Anfang noch nicht mal ihre eigenen Module richtig erkannt.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das musst du erst mal auf die Reihe kriegen.
So.
Aber mittlerweile funktioniert es eigentlich ganz gut.
Und witzigerweise muss ich sagen, bei dem Mikro-Tick-Switch, bei diesem 10...
Ich weiß nicht...
Der mit vier Ports.
Ja, der da.
Genau.
Bei denen hatte ich bisher noch keine Modul-Probleme.
Aber den verwende ich auch nicht.
Den habe ich nur zum Ausprobieren da.
Und mit Direct-Attach-Kabel überlege ich gerade.
Bisher hat das alles funktioniert.
Ich habe eine wilde Mischung da.
Ich habe nämlich immer die billigsten gekauft, die es gab.
Ich habe, glaube ich...
Ich habe ein paar gebrauchte Cisco-Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Ein paar gebrauchte HP-Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Irgendwelche No-Name-Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Die haben bisher alle funktioniert.
Aber ja, generell sind die bei Modulen immer ziemlich wählerig, die Switchen.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, es wird besser.
Da lohnt sich Firmware-Update tatsächlich mal bei Switchen.
Ja, der ist übrigens eh echt gut.
Wenn ihr den 10-Gigabit-Switch...
Wie gesagt, ich müsste langsam Geld dafür bekommen, wie oft ich Mikrotex-Sachen empfehle.
Aber wenn ihr den 10-Gigabit-Switch für daheim sucht, der ist wirklich gut.
Kostet um die 100 Euro.
Und ihr bekommt 14 Gigabit-Ports und einen 1-Gigabit-Port.
Was echt gut ist.
Es gibt keinen vergleichbaren Switch preis-leistungsmäßig, der das bietet, was das Ding hat.
Dazu kommt noch, der hat sogar duale Netzteile und ist lüfterlos.
Also sprich, der ist auch noch leise.
Das in Kombination ist echt selten.
Also, ich zeige es euch mal von hinten.
Also, ihr wisst schon.
Man sieht, dass man zwei Netzteile anschließen kann.
Also, das ist wirklich selten in dieser Kategorie.
Doppelte Netzteile.
Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich würde ich sogar nur eins anschließen, weil das Ding fehlt.
Na ja.
Gut, auf der anderen Seite.
Ihr wisst ja, was als erstes gefällt.
Oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das noch wisst.
Ich habe es ja gezeigt.
Also hier, nur mal kurz zu meinem Rack.
So Leute, wisst ihr, was davon kaputt gegangen ist?
Als allererstes.
Ihr seht was besser.
Wisst ihr, was davon als erstes kaputt gegangen ist?
Also, wir hätten hier die Ausfahrt.
Der Server, der Switch, irgendwelche Panels, der andere Switch, irgendwelche Dinger.
Die USV.
Ohne Scheiß, die USV.
Oh, das Ding, was dafür sorgen soll.
Dass es keine oder wenige Ausfälle gibt.
Die ist zuerst kaputt gegangen.
Dabei ist das gar keine Ultra-Crap-No-Name-USV.
Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob einfach nur die Batterien komplett RIP sind.
Oder sonst was.
Ich betreibe das jetzt einfach ohne USV gerade.
Gibt es von MikroTik einen guten Desktop-Switch mit circa 10 Ports?
Ja, 50 verschiedene.
Die haben wirklich massig.
Du musst dich einfach mal durchgucken.
Also, der beste...
Also, wenn man ein Arbeitszimmer hat.
Man möchte sowohl 10G als auch 1G verwenden und hat halt recht viele Geräte.
Der beste Switch ist der hier.
Also, der hat ja eindeutig zu wenig Ports.
Ich meine, man kann natürlich den nehmen und noch was anderes dran anschließen.
Der beste Switch war das...
Genau, einmal der.
Und dann gibt es noch welche mit 4 Ports.
Einmal preislich.
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig ist das Ding für so ein Arbeitszimmer unschlagbar.
Das Ding ist wirklich Poggers.
Man bekommt...
Man bekommt 2 10-Gigabit-Ports und ich glaube 24...
Oder was sind denn das?
8, 16, ja 24.
Und man bekommt 24 Gigabit-Ports.
Für 140 Euro.
Also, mal ganz im Ernst.
Da kannst du dich wirklich nicht beschweren für.
So.
Die gleiche Variante gibt es auch noch als Router-Ausführung mit Router-OS.
Aber es ist die gleiche Hardware.
Das lohnt sich.
Meiner Meinung nach nur bedingt.
Es gibt noch hier ein CRS 3.
2.
Den gibt es auch noch.
Der kostet immer 40 Euro mehr.
Der Unterschied...
Äh, Moment.
Ah, guck mal, das ist der Neue.
Das ist der Neue.
Aha.
Was ist da jetzt der Unterschied?
2S.
Und das ist Plus-In.
Plus-RM.
Was ist RM?
Remote Management?
Ne, was ist RM und was ist In?
Was ist der Unterschied dazwischen?
Ich bin bei der Mikrotik-Bezeichnung manchmal ein bisschen lost.
Ah, Rackmount.
Rackmount.
Genau, also die Dinger sind wirklich gut, wenn ihr euch mal anguckt.
Guck mal, für 100...
Alter.
Ich meine mal ernsthaft.
Guckt mal, das ist quasi...
Also okay, es ist doof zu sagen, es ist geschenkt für 105 Euro, ja?
Aber 105 Euro für einen Switch, kommt mir vor wie beim Shopping-Kanal gerade.
105 Euro für einen 24-Port-Gigabit und zwei Ports 10G, das ist wirklich ein Superpreis.
Da kann man sich null...
...beschweren.
So, und dann gibt es noch die Router-Variante davon.
Ist die gleiche Hardware.
Lohnt sich meiner Meinung nach nur bedingt.
Man hat zwar mehr Optionen, man hat zwar komplettes Router-OS drauf.
Und kann damit mehr Sachen machen als mit dem anderen Switch.
Aber sowohl CPU-mäßig als auch intern von der Anbieter ist das nicht unbedingt als Router so gedacht.
Ja.
Gucken, ob da immer noch...
...die gleiche Hardware drin ist.
Ach, der Megahertz-CPU.
Steht gar nicht dabei, was da für eine CPU drin ist.
Interessiert nicht.
Aber ist wahrscheinlich immer noch das Gleiche.
Tja.
Ah, das ist nice.
Wozu braucht man 24 Ports im Heimbereich?
Besser Ports haben, als Ports brauchen.
Ich meine, wenn du guckst, was du hier am Start hast...
Warte mal.
Übelst muss ich gerade...
Übelst hust, was ist denn los?
Also ich meine, ich habe hier zwei Rechner stehen.
Ich habe eins, zwei, drei Konsolen stehen.
So.
Ich habe einen Drucker stehen.
Ich habe noch hier ein paar Raspberry-Sons wie zum Testen und alles mögliche.
Also zehn Ports brauche ich vorneweg.
Hier im Arbeitszimmer.
So.
Gut.
Da ist die Hälfte schon mal fast zu.
Ohne hinten den Serverraum dabei.
Also die Hälfte ist schon mal fast voll.
Also Hälfte Ports haben ist doch gut.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Du bezahlst ja davon nicht mehr.
Du findest keinen Switch, der, sagen wir mal...
Das Gleiche hat aber mit nur zwölf Ports und dafür die Hälfte kostet.
Also nimmt man doch die 24 Ports mit und hat nach oben offen.
Man bezahlt ja noch nicht mal großartig was.
Also wozu?
Warum?
Warum sparen an den Ports irgendwie?
Die haben bei MikroTik auch kleinere, aber das lohnt sich meiner Meinung nach.
Ich meine, 100 Euro für so einen Switch, 24 Gigabit und einen 10...
Was überlegt man da noch lang?
Ja.
Ich sollte mir mal...
Ich sollte mir mal einen MikroTik Amazon-Links generieren lassen.
Ja.
Unbedingt, ey.
Guck mal.
Bei Amazon kostet der einfach 70 Euro mehr.
Ah, nee, das ist ja CRS.
Okay.
Bei Amazon kostet der ganze Kram mehr.
Aber es ist halt Amazon.
Okay, also.
Was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Die besten Singleboard-Computer auf 2020.
Auf 2020.
Alles klar.
Warum Nike?
Weil es keine Steuern bezahlt.
Der Intel Dishwasher.
Oh ja.
Ja, den musst du mir jetzt angucken.
Der ist exzellent.
Also, das ist fake, by the way.
Gibt ja Leute, die nehmen das immer für voll.
Exzellent.
Ist das ein PCI?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ist da ein PCI-Slot drin?
Und IDE?
Okay, wisst ihr, woran das liegt?
Nee, das sind SATA-Ports.
Das liegt daran, weil der Typ für seine komische Animationssoftware
sich irgendwo ein kostenloses Mainboard-Model runtergeladen hat.
Und das hat halt noch einen PCI-Slot gehabt.
Ah, yes.
Ein Schnapper.
Ah.
Let's take a closer look.
All Intel Dishwasher Units feature an updated platform controller hub
with CNVIO2 controller.
And includes Wi-Fi 6 and external AX201 CRF module support.
Dishwashers can be configured to include up to...
Oldschool CPUs mit Pins.
32 Core Processors with onboard Intel Iris 655 integrated GPU technology.
Der heizt wahrscheinlich mit der CPU.
5.3 Gigahertz.
The Intel Dishwasher offers a high performance multi-threaded dishwashing experience
that supports the latest cutting edge...
...EDR 42933 RAM technologies.
Attach the optional heatsink and cooler...
Oh!
Das ist so...
Es ist so bescheuert, aber es ist schon was wahres dran.
Intel, also Pentium 4s, sind übelst heiß geworden.
Aber über Tacken kann man auch noch.
Exquisite.
Intel uses Intel's 14 nanometer technology with second generation tri-gay transistors
to deliver industry leading performance in power with the new Skylake...
Alter!
...high performance dishwashing technology will transform the dishwashing industry.
Intel, washing the dishes today for a better tomorrow.
Das ist Schwachsinn, Alter.
Okay, was gucken wir da?
Was?
Das 0 Euro Budget Freenas.
Okay.
Ist das wieder ein Video in die Richtung, wo wir schon mal was geguckt haben?
So nach dem Motto 0 Euro, aber 200 Euro Fahrtkosten.
Ist das wieder sowas?
Kennst du schon Nvidia Bread?
High Quality Brot?
Ne, kenn ich nicht.
Leise.
Ich beschäftige mich heute einmal und ich hoffe das letzte Mal...
...mit dem zweiten 0 Euro...
0 Euro PC und versuche da auf dem Ding ein Freenas-System aufzusetzen, nachdem das so bei der täglichen Nutzbarkeit in Richtung Windows und Linux nicht ganz so toll funktioniert hat.
Achso, ich dachte er baut das jetzt zusammen.
Ach ne, jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt er nochmal.
...linke ich hier oben, damit man ungefähr sieht, was da für Teile drin verbaut sind.
Ich werde darauf jetzt nicht nochmal genau eingehen.
Möchte allerdings, dass ihr Bescheid wisst, was da drin verbaut ist und wie ich da dran gekommen bin.
Also ich habe die Sachen abgeholt.
Die gab es bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen.
Ja, das war ein Video, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war ein Video, 0 Euro PC, aber 200 Euro Fahrtkosten.
Und das Gute ist eigentlich, und was das jetzt auch so richtig möglich macht, ist eigentlich, dass ich insgesamt vier Festplatten angesammelt habe.
Und wir deswegen dann auch ein paar Daten speichern können.
Ganze vier Festplatten.
Wir schauen mal.
Gut, wenn es 10 Terabyte Festplatten sind, ist es ordentlich.
Aber ich vermute mal eher nicht.
Angesammelt bedeutet, das ist wahrscheinlich so eine Mischung aus 500G bis 2 Terabyte oder so.
Ich kann das Ding eigentlich...
Ich kann das Ding eigentlich nicht mehr sehen.
Es sieht schon räulich aus, ja.
Es sieht schon räulich aus, das Ding.
Ich finde das Ding so hässlich.
Ja.
Naja.
Vor allem der Lüfter da unten drin.
The fuck?
Wofür ist der Lüfter?
Ist der, weil die Grafikkarte sonst abkackt oder wie?
Das machen wir heute.
Ich versuche hiermit so eine Art Freenas-System aufzubauen.
Ich habe damit schon mal rumgespielt und dann...
Und was hängt denn da?
Ist das irgendein Sasa-Kabel oder was hängt da rum?
...es feststellen können.
Dass man auf der Festplatte oder auf dem USB-Stick, wo man Freenas installieren möchte,
keine Daten drauf speichern kann, auf die man dann später das Netzwerk zugreifen kann.
Wer gar nicht weiß, was Freenas an sich ist...
Aber Freenas...
Da hast du quasi...
Freenas, ich habe Freenas eine Weile verwendet, ich habe da keinen F mal drauf gehabt.
...attached storage, das heißt...
Ich mache jetzt den absoluten Easy-Mode aktuell bei mir gerade.
Einfach eine 12T-Platte, XFS drauf, Samba-Server.
Fertig.
Also auf einer Kiste, die sonst noch ein paar andere Sachen macht.
Und das war's.
Einmal in der Nacht, AirSync-Backup, fertig.
Dateiserver, das heißt, wenn das Ding irgendwo läuft, irgendwo in eurem Laden zu Hause,
dann könnt ihr von einem anderen PC drauf zugreifen.
Ich habe gerade nochmal nachgeschaut im Video, welche Festplatten...
Da kommen jetzt...
Ey, ey, ey, wisst ihr was?
Wenn du solche Videos Freenas auf Reddit postest,
dann sind die ganzen Freenas-Experten übelst getriggert.
So nach dem Motto, was du verwendest.
Du hast kein ECC-RAM.
Anzeige ist raus.
Ohne ECC-RAM.
Hier, das ist ja fast schon kriminell, ohne ECC-RAM.
Dann kommen die Nächsten an.
Dann kommen die Nächsten Leute an.
Du hast viel zu wenig RAM.
Du brauchst mindestens 1 GB pro TB Speicher...
Oder was?
Irgendwie sowas.
Oder 2 GB pro TB Speicherplatz.
Oder irgendwie sowas, was sie immer empfehlen.
Viel zu wenig.
Viel zu wenig RAM.
Kannst du nicht machen.
Ich sage euch, das...
Vor allem das offizielle Freenas-Forum ist ein...
Wie sagt man da so schön?
Es ist Circle Jerk.
Keine Ahnung.
Ein...
Ja.
Kreisgewichse ohne Ende eher.
Das Freenas-Forum ist so ein massive, pepeger Ort.
Das ist echter Wahnsinn.
Dabei stimmt das ja noch nicht mal.
Das trifft höchstens zu, was die Leute da immer erzählen.
Das trifft höchstens zu unter Bedingungen, wenn du so ein Ding in einem Büro verwenden willst,
wo wirklich ordentlich I.O. ist.
Oder für eine Abteilung als Netzwerk...
Storage oder sowas.
Okay, dann lasse ich mir das gefallen.
Aber für den Heimbereich, es ist ja nicht so, als wird ZFS ohne ECC-RAM unsicherer als ein normales File-System.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
ZFS hat ja die ganzen Checksum-Geschichten und sonstige Sachen zusätzlich zu einem normalen File-System.
Hat es ja dann auch schon.
Die einzige Sache, die dir halt passieren kann, ist, dass wenn dein RAM kaputt ist,
und ZFS dort irgendwelche Checks durchführt, die dann fehlschlagen, obwohl sie nicht fehlschlagen sollten,
oder funktionieren, obwohl sie nicht funktionieren sollten.
Also sprich, dass ZFS Fehler nicht erkennt, die es mit ECC-RAM erkennen könnte.
Das ist ja das Einzige.
Das macht es nicht schlechter.
Ein anderes File-System kriegt das erst gar nicht mit.
Hat erst gar nicht die Chance, das mitzubekommen.
Also ganz ehrlich, das offizielle FreeNAS-Forum ist wirklich pepega-place.
So. Gucken wir mal weiter.
... es gibt ja einmal das Ding und dann noch diesen fetten Bomber dort.
Ja, ne?
Und, ja, da gab es ja viel Festplatten.
Exquisite, oldschool Festplatten, wenn du spielst.
Da fehlt bloß noch was mit IDE.
... Platten zu und ich kann mir vorstellen, so beim zweiten Teil habe ich ja das riesige Gehäuse gekriegt
und damit auch ein paar Sachen ausprobiert.
Da bin ich sehr zuversichtlich, da läuft FreeNAS drauf.
Ja, Coupan.
... hat ja auch nichts gekostet.
Terabyte, SSD, kann man sich immer machen.
Man kann...
Es gibt eh prinzipiell nur eine Sache.
Man kann nicht genug SSDs haben.
Man kann immer nur mehr SSDs.
SSDs lohnen sich immer.
Und im Zweifelsfall macht man aus alten SSDs mit einem Adapter-USB-Sticks.
Ich habe hier vier Festplatten gekriegt und ich werde jetzt die kleinste hier von dem nehmen.
Nämlich diese hier.
Sagenhafte.
... installieren.
Wie viel?
... genug SATA-Anschlüsse. Ja, haben wir, okay.
Ist ja eher so ein billig Mainboard.
Wie viel ist drauf?
Dann würde ich versuchen, die beiden Platten als Speicher zu verwenden.
Ja, excellent.
Ich habe einmal mit FreeNAS gearbeitet.
Ja, exzellent.
Also einmal ein Setup gemacht.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn du die Platten hier hast und die eine ist 1T und die andere 2T, dann wird das so mit einem ZFS-Mirror nichts.
Also doch, du kannst die mirrorn, aber das zählt nur die kleinere.
Und bei ZFS hast du ja auch prinzipiell das Problem, dass du die Sachen nicht nachträglich erweitern kannst.
Du kannst nur einen zweiten Mirror oder sowas machen.
Oder du kannst die Sachen replacen, wenn einer kaputt ist.
Aber quasi so on the fly erweitern.
So on the fly erweitern ist da nicht.
Da hat sich aber in den letzten zwei Jahren extrem viel getan, was ZFS angeht.
Es ist möglich, dass das outdated ist, was ich erzähle.
Und das mittlerweile geht.
Gibt es auch Probleme bei unterschiedlichen Geschwindigkeiten?
Ja, in der Regel kann man immer sagen, das Langsamere gilt.
In der Regel.
Also in der Regel kann man sagen, die langsameren Sachen und die kleineren Sachen sind immer die, die gelten.
Also sprich, hast du eine 1TB lahme Festplatte.
Mit einer 2TB superschnellen SSD zusammen, dann ist die SSD nur noch 1TB.
Und wenn du es gesynct schreibst, ist es im Prinzip dann die SSD, bringt dir nichts.
Also im Prinzip kann man eigentlich so unterm Strich immer sagen, es zählt immer das Langsamere.
Das heißt, es ist ziemlich sinnlos, was Ultraschnelles und was ziemlich Langsames zu kombinieren.
Zumindest in einem Mirror.
Muss sich natürlich erst herausfinden, ja okay, da muss eine zweite Festplatte rein, sonst kann man auf die Daten nicht zugreifen.
Was wir jetzt brauchen, ist ein bootbarer USB-Stick.
Ja, eine Festplatte.
Hätte man noch ein paar, siehste, siehste, ich sage es immer wieder.
USB auf SATA Adapter, Easy SSD und davon booten.
Ich habe, ich habe jetzt, ich habe hier zwei alte 2TB ähm äh 32G SSDs liegen.
Die verwende ich mittlerweile als USB-Sticks und das sind die besten USB-Sticks, die es gibt.
Warum deine Maus in Battlefield 3 funktioniert, das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Eigentlich bei sowas.
Wohl weiß ich gar nicht, ob das so super funktioniert.
Wir, wir werden es ja gleich sehen.
Ich lade mir mal eben die ISO-Datei runter und dann versuchen wir es hier nochmal mit Ventoy.
Das ist ja so ein Multi-Boot-System.
Hier.
Chat, Hand aufs Herz.
Wer hatte auch schon so einen USB-Stick?
Ich, ich tippe mal auf jeder.
Diese USB-Sticks, die hatte jeder schon mal.
Gibt es, es gibt keinen, der nicht, was, was ist das hier?
Was da in der Steckdose, was ist denn das?
Sieht aus wie ein Schraubendrehergriff, der, was auch immer das ist.
Was ist das da in der Steckdose?
Die sacken richtig hart, ja.
Ja, die sind mega scheiße.
Hier können sie dann die ISO-Dateien draufpacken und dann sollte das funktionieren.
Jetzt frage ich mich aber, ob der PC nach dem langen, der wurde ein bisschen bewegt, aber der stand sonst nur rum, wurde nicht benutzt.
Ob wir hier überhaupt ein Bild kriegen, ob wir damit arbeiten können.
Oh, VGA.
Wir können dann auch endlich diese wirklich sehr, sehr hässliche, sehr, sehr schlechte Grafikkarte endlich mal ausbauen.
Radeon X300SE.
Oh, yes.
Das Ding kann gar nichts.
Es reicht zum Booten.
Es ist genug dafür.
Falls es jetzt dazu kommt, so wie ich es hier vermute, dass der PC zwar angeht, aber kein Bild macht und auch nicht hochfährt, habe ich ein Video erstellt.
Verlinke ich hier oben.
Heißt Hilfe, mein PC macht kein Bild.
Dort habe ich eine Art Leitfaden eingebaut, wo man anfangen kann zu suchen, wenn der PC nicht funktioniert.
Meistens ist es der Arbeitsspeicher oder irgendein Kontaktproblem.
Arbeitsspeicher oder Grafikkarte.
Wenn der PC kein Bild macht, einfach neuen PC kaufen.
Ganz einfach.
Hier ist echt nichts.
Und das Ganze wiederholt man so lange, bis der PC Bild macht.
Über diesen Lüfter hier reingesetzt, was ich dann gehofft habe.
Freifährt.
Dass vielleicht grafiktechnisch irgendwie ein klitzekleines bisschen mehr möglich ist.
Weil die Grafikkarte wohl schon echt heiß wurde.
Ja siehst du, die Grafikkarte ist das Problem, beziehungsweise der Slot.
Das läuft hier auf jeden Fall so, dass man hier seine ISO-Dateien hat, die sich irgendwo auf dem USB-Stick befinden.
Und da sagen wir, hier Harrens Boot CD hätte ich jetzt gerne.
Richtig oldschool VGA, ja.
Es würde sich da vielleicht auch empfehlen, einen schnellen USB-Stick zu verwenden.
Es geht.
Die Freenas-Installation geht, sage ich.
... was angeboten.
Irgendwie so ein Gehäuse mit einer vorkonfigurierten Software und Aufklebern für mich und sowas.
Irgendwie fällt mir das jetzt gerade erst wieder ein.
Ist aber auch schon zwei Monate her.
Und nein, dieser USB-Stick ist nicht schnell.
Das sind irgendwelche Dinger von Intenso.
Und das war irgendwie so eine Woche gewesen.
Ich wollte mir nichts bestellen.
Ich wollte was lokal abholen.
Ich wollte aber auch keine 50 Euro für einen USB-Stick ausgeben mit 32 Gigabyte oder sowas.
Deswegen, ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen, einfach mal einen Pack SATA zu USB-Adapter kaufen.
Und alte SSDs als USB-Stick verwenden.
Es gibt nichts besseres.
Ja, sowas halbwegs günstiges war dann eben von Intenso mit USB 3.
Ich dachte mir, ja, ist ja USB 3, kann ja nicht so langsam sein.
Ja, denkt man.
Also ich habe dabei so USB 2 Sticks gehabt, die schneller waren als das Ding.
Und wenn man heutzutage noch Speicher verkauft, der langsamer ist als LAN zum Beispiel oder...
USB 3 ist ja im Prinzip nur die Schnittstelle.
Denn wenn der Flash ultra langsam ist, das geht schon.
Aber das ist halt so Billig-China-Crap.
Ne, ich meine, teilweise das WLAN in unserer Firma und wahrscheinlich auch hier ist schneller als der USB-Stick da.
Warum gibt es sowas immer noch?
Locker.
Ich meine, Restbestände, schön und gut, aber... ne?
Die Frage der Fragen ist eigentlich eher, warum kauft man sich's und vor allem warum benutzt man's?
Das ist dann Rückschritt so.
Und der braucht immer sehr, sehr lange hier.
Also kann auch sein, dass jetzt gar nichts mehr geht, weil total langsam ist auch egal.
Bam.
So, jetzt haben wir diese Datei drauf und dann schauen wir mal, was passiert.
Es wird ja 64-Bit-CPU empfohlen und... oder auch wahrscheinlich vorausgesetzt und 8 GB RAM.
Ich glaube, da sind vier drin.
Wird noch lustig werden.
Leider hat das jetzt nicht geklappt mit dem Stick.
Also, der wurde zwar gefunden und wollte auch booten, aber irgendwie wollte der PC das Laufwerk zwar erkennen, mir aber nichts anzeigen.
Weil ich jetzt aber keine Lust habe, den Stick zu zerkauen oder so, habe ich einen anderen genommen.
Zerkauen?
Da verwende ich den Rufus.
Dann klicken wir auf Auswahl, wählen die Datei aus, die wir dann runtergeladen haben, also die ISO-Datei.
Klicken auf Start.
Ah, USB-Stick-Plätzchen.
Und gleich gibt's dann die Meldung, ja, hat funktioniert, fertig, ist grün.
So sollte es dann ungefähr aussehen.
Wisst ihr, was die einfachste Variante ist?
Einfach DD.
Oder für die Leute, die unter Linux und GUI brauchen, Etcher.
Etcher ist so ein Tool, wo die Daseinsberechtigung sich mir absolut nicht erschließt, aber ich verwende es auch.
Eigentlich merkwürdig, ne?
Man könnte einfach die Sache auf den USB-Stick DD, aber nein, man macht es mit Etcher.
Oder auf die Micro-SD-Karte.
Einziges Tool, was ich verwende, wo ich eigentlich nicht genau weiß, warum es es gibt.
DD ist das Kommandozeilen-Tool unter Linux, mit dem man auf Block-Devices schreibt.
Also du schreibst einfach DD, Input-File und dann Output-File.
Und Output-File nimmst du halt das Device, also in dem Fall Def, SD, A oder SD-A1 oder SD-B oder SD-C, je nachdem, was dein USB-Stick ist.
Und dann schreibt er das.
Also im Prinzip ist es total unsinnig, dass es solche Sachen wie Etcher gibt, aber ich muss euch halt sagen, ich verwende es auch.
Und ich weiß gar nicht warum.
Also in dem Fall ist es halt einfacher.
Einfach auf ISO öffnen oder sogar ZIP öffnen klicken, der es da unten darüber auspackt und draufschreibt.
F10, F11, F12.
Das variiert immer von Hersteller zu Hersteller.
Bei OEM-Mainboards kann es auch sein, dass es das gar nicht gibt oder dass es auch mal Escape ist oder Tab.
Also dazu in der Anleitung schauen.
Oder wir gehen ins BIOS.
Ist üblicherweise F1 entfernt.
By the way, nachdem das Video noch lang geht, ich muss mal kurz noch was beantworten aus dem Chat.
Irgendjemand hat mich gerade gefragt, ob ich denke, dass das hier was taugt.
Mal gucken.
HPZ440 Workstation Intel Xeon.
Ganz schön teuer, oder?
Für so olles Zeug.
Wobei, ist das alt?
Wie alt ist denn das?
Von wann sind denn die CPUs?
2014.
Ganz schön teuer, oder?
Ah gut, ich meine, die haben schon ordentlich RAM drin.
Ja, ne?
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
12 Core, 64G RAM.
Das ist aber noch DDR3, hä?
Oder was ist da für RAM drin?
Sieht man nicht.
DDR3, ja.
Das ist halt Technik aus dem letzten Jahrzehnt.
Naja, stimmt nicht ganz aus.
Also, auf jeden Fall schon 5 Jahre plus alt.
Definitiv nicht stromsparend.
Dazu kommt, dass an sich halt sowohl DDR3 als auch die CPU, damit reißt auch nichts mehr wahnsinnig aus.
Aber sie sind immer noch ziemlich schnell, dadurch dass sie viel Kerne haben.
Also, wenn du Multithreaded Workload hast, die SSD kannst du wahrscheinlich vergessen.
Die Festplatte auch.
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, 700 Euro erscheint mir doch...
Ist DDR4?
Da steht aber DDR3.
Ach, Moment.
Die Grafiker.
Ah, ich habe mich verguckt.
Okay, es ist DDR4.
Gut, letztendlich macht es das jetzt auch nicht fett.
Ich muss dir sagen, ein bisschen teuer erscheint es mir.
Nämlich aus dem Grund, dafür bekommst du ja heute fast schon... fast, ja.
Fast schon ein aktuelles...
Ein aktuelles Ryzen-Bild.
Natürlich nicht mit 64G und nicht mit 5900 oder sowas.
Also, für das, dass es so alt ist, muss ich sagen, finde ich es fast schon ein bisschen teuer.
Auf der anderen Seite, man muss gucken, was es sonst so als Alternative gibt.
Und wenn du halt gerade Workload hast, der das da haben will...
Aber ganz im Ernst, eigentlich braucht man sowas daheim nicht.
Was machst du daheim, was 12 Kerne 64G braucht?
Vor allem dauerhaft.
Wenn man einfach nur mal kurz was machen will...
Dann ist es am besten, man mietet sich irgendeine Cloud-Kiste mit 64Kern und haut da drauf.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich ab und zu mal OpenStreetMaps processe, dann kaufe ich mir auch irgendeine Cloud-Kiste.
64 Kerne, 690G RAM.
Bäm.
Dann ist das in 2 Stunden durch und am Ende habe ich 2,50€ bezahlt.
Gut, und das Ding braucht halt ordentlich Strom.
Es kommt, ich würde sagen, es kommt ganz entscheidend auf den Anwendungszweck an, ob sich das lohnt.
Einfach nur für einen Server, den man daheim stehen haben will, wo man noch keine konkreten Pläne hat.
Was man damit machen will, würde ich sagen, ist es total Oversize und auch zu teuer und braucht auch zu viel Strom.
Virtualisieren mit 7v1 für mein Labornetz.
Dafür könnte es sich tatsächlich lohnen, ja.
Je nachdem, was du für VMs machst.
Ich meine, 7 VMs an sich brauchen ja keine Leistung großartig.
Kommt halt drauf an, was die VMs machen.
Mein Socken ist kaputt.
Sehe ich gerade.
Weiß nicht, wie ich da gerade drauf komme.
Ich bin gerade hängen geblieben am Schreibtisch und habe gedacht, warum ist es denn so kühl am Fuß?
Ich sehe, mein Socken hat ein Loch.
Exzellent.
Ja, also wie gesagt, 7 VMs für ein Labornetz.
Das könnte durchaus gut sein.
Gut damit funktionieren, aber die Frage ist halt, was du mit den VMs machst.
Weil einfach nur VMs starten und ein bisschen was drauf laufen lassen, braucht ja auch nichts.
Also nicht viel.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde es mir wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen.
Ich würde es mir wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen, weil es ist uralt, es ist laut, es braucht Strom in Massen.
Es hat zwar fette Leistung, aber quasi fette Leistung aus dem letzten Jahrzehnt.
Welche Workstation würdest du bis 800 Euro empfehlen?
Boah, da kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen.
Da müsste ich mich mit aktueller Technik immer beschäftigen.
Preis-Leistungsmäßig sind ältere Sachen ja prinzipiell nicht verkehrt.
Wenn man damit leben kann, dass es halt meistens Strom verbraucht und laut ist.
Also es ist halt die Frage, was du brauchst.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du 12 Kerne brauchst.
Und auch für die VMs eben lieber irgendwas günstigeres, kleines.
Kommt halt drauf an, was für VMs sein müssen.
Also wie gesagt, aktuelle PC Sachen, ich kann dir da nicht so viel empfehlen.
Ich kann dir in dem Fall nur sagen, bei dieser einen Sache auf Ebay, das ist was, ich würde es mir wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen.
Was jetzt nicht heißt, dass es für deinen Anwendungszweck gar nicht passt oder so.
So, lass mal weiter gucken.
Was machst du mit OpenStreetMaps?
Ich habe mit einem Arbeitskollege was programmiert, aber das ist jetzt ein bisschen eingeschlafen in den letzten Monaten.
Wo sich Handwerker, die OpenStreetMaps machen.
Die optimale Route inklusive halt Terminvergabe.
Also je nachdem mit welchem Kunden du welchen Termin ausgemacht hast, berechnet dir das die optimale Route.
Wie du quasi von deinem Startpunkt mit deinen Technikern verteilst auf Autos und wie die am besten die Kunden anfahren.
Habe was gebastelt zu und die Visualisierung ist OpenStreetMaps.
Die Routenplanung ist nicht OpenStreetMaps.
Also die Routenplanung ist auf Basis von OpenStreetMaps.
Aber nicht mit OpenStreetMaps.
Pfeifert, nee das ist sogar relativ einfach zu programmieren 1337, weil wir komplett fertige Libraries verwenden dafür.
Wir machen das ja gar nicht selbst.
Wir haben eigentlich nur ein ordentliches WebUI dazu gebaut.
Und das Interessante ist aber sogar eher was die sich wünschen dafür.
Welchen Algorithmus habt ihr für die Routenberechnung verwendet?
Keine Ahnung, ich bin Lowbrain.
Ich habe was fertiges verwendet.
Also die Auflösung lenkt Breitengrad und Adressen und sonst was.
Wo das ist, koordinatenmäßig machen wir über Google Maps.
Weil Google Maps die beste Autocompletion und solche Geschichten hat.
Alles andere machen wir nicht über Google Maps, weil das zu teuer wird.
Also sprich die Routenberechnung machen wir über Google Maps.
Und auf Basis von OrtMos Streetmaps haben wir ein OrtMos Source Projekt für Github.
Da kannst du angeben, wie viele Autos du hast.
Also quasi Autos gleich Techniker im Folgen.
Also du machst das nicht auf Personenbasis.
Du sagst alle, ok ich habe zwei interne Linie.
Installateur ADHD-Lkw oder so oder Installator Autos, die können rumfahren.
Dann hast du eine Kundendatenbank.
Und dann kannst du sagen welche Termine du hast,
und der kann dir dann auch sagen,
anhand der Time Slots, die du da ausgemacht hast, die optimale Route berechnen.
Also das ist nicht Travelling Salesman, das ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Das ist, ähm, frag mich nicht, Travelling Salesman Spezial mit Time Windows Sachen.
Aber das Gute ist, ich muss nicht selbst programmieren.
Wir benutzen ein fertiges Projekt für GitHub.
Das braucht als Basis ein preprocessed Set von OpenStreetMaps.
Das ist das, was ich über die Cloud-Kiste ab und zu preprocesse, wo ich dann eine 64-Kerne-Kiste miete.
Und anhand dessen kannst du das machen.
Der Server selbst braucht dann deutlich weniger.
Wie die das unter der Haube machen, Algorithmen-technisch, keine Ahnung.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, interessiert mich auch nicht. Es funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Also wenn du durchschnittlich 70% CPU hast mit einer 8-Core-CPU, dann hast du wahrscheinlich mehr als 99% der Leute daheim.
Dann kann sich sowas Fettes natürlich schon lohnen.
So, wir gucken jetzt erst mal das Fertige.
Ah ja, ja.
Dann gehen wir auf Boot. Hier steht jetzt Start.
Exzellent, Boot. Ich will mal kurz gucken, wo es weitergeht.
Moment, der installiert jetzt FreeNAS hier. Das müssen wir uns nicht angucken. Das ist doch übelst langweilig.
So, jetzt haben wir FreeNAS am Start.
Was? Ne, das ist nicht FreeNAS.
Drauf.
Winners.
Draw Winners.
Der macht jetzt irgendwelche Verlosungsstells. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Okay, das ist FreeNAS.
Ja, okay, das ist dann doch nicht so spannend.
Was haben wir hier?
Was unser Internet auch gar nicht schafft.
Aber kann ja sein, dass ich hier vielleicht noch diesen wunderschönen Karton...
Oh, exzellent, exzellent.
Das Soundkarten-PCI-Soundkarten oder was ist das hier?
Ah ne, WLAN.
Ne, ich benutze diese Karten nie.
Doch, das ist eine Soundkarte.
Ja, soll ich die alle einzeln einpacken und dann...
Okay, in dem Video.
Passiert nicht allzu viel, das muss jetzt nicht fertig ankommen.
What the fuck ist das?
Quasi eingerichtet.
Das ist...
Das ist ja so groß wie mein Daumen.
Das ist ja mal wirklich...
Mikro... Mikroskopisch kleine PCI-Karte.
Wahrscheinlich ist das eine Netzwerkkarte oder was ist das?
Und dann später habe ich zwischen dem Neustart die Karte wieder eingesetzt.
Und er meint...
Wenn ich jetzt etwas konfigurieren möchte...
Ja, das ist Netzwerk.
...nur RE0 verwenden.
Und das ist auch die Karte, weil er über die interne LAN-Karte oder den internen LAN-Controller...
Das ist ja geil.
...ich arbeiten konnte.
Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt so funktioniert.
Und dann sollte ich auf jeden Fall...
Ja, ja.
...vorher schwarz-warhaftig...
...erst hier auf Netzwerk gehen.
So, easy performance, zeig her.
...hättet ihr hier nicht die IP-Adresse nachträglich ändern.
Das hat er selber gemacht.
IP-Leak!
...gemacht hat.
Der hat es selbstständig erkannt.
Ja, okay.
Wir haben jetzt eine andere IP-Adresse.
Können wir hier mal schauen.
Geschwindigkeit.
Auch, ja.
Das sieht man nicht.
Das ging alles in Cash.
Ich habe gedacht, komm, fürs Video.
Wenn das jetzt auch anhebt, klappt, dann...
Nee, das hat es jetzt nicht so gebracht, ehrlich gesagt.
So, also, warum Nike fast keine Steuern bezahlt?
Ja, zeig mal her.
Nike ist der weltweite...
Sorry, Nike.
Man muss das ja...
Wir sind ja cool, ja.
Man muss die Sachen auch ordentlich aussprechen.
Wir waren hier...
...Artikelhersteller, deutlich vor Adidas.
Gleichzeitig ist Nike auf Platz 13 der wertvollsten Marken der Welt.
By the way, Amazon bezahlt auch kaum Steuern.
Amerikanische Unternehmen beschäftigt über 70.000 Personen und betreibt global über 1.000 eigene Geschäfte.
Ah, yes.
Der Konzern macht jedes Jahr Milliardengewinne.
Einiges davon auch in Deutschland.
Grundsätzlich müsste Nike diese Gewinne versteuern.
Was ist das für Musik im Hintergrund?
Das ist nicht bei mir, das ist im Video.
Die Idee dahinter ist...
Die Idee ist simpel.
Wer Ressourcen nutzt und damit Geld verdient, soll einen Teil dieses Geldes an das Gemeinwesen zurückgeben.
Damit sollen dann beispielsweise Schulen, Krankenhäuser und Straßen gebaut werden.
Außerdem soll sichergestellt werden, dass niemand in Armut leben muss.
Leider zahlt Nike fast gar keine Steuern.
Zumindest nicht in Deutschland.
Und das ist sogar legal.
Heute geht es um undurchsichtige Briefkastenfirmen, komplizierte Steuerkonstrukte...
Oh, Big Brain Logik.
...und unversteuerte Millionen.
...und unversteuerte Milliarden auf den Bermudas.
Ah, yes.
Letztlich geht es darum, wie solche Schlupflöcher das Fundament unserer Gesellschaft untergraben.
Der muss ja sagen, eins kann der, eins kann der echt gut.
Der kann die Sachen immer so bedeutungsvoll betonen.
Im November 2017 veröffentlichte die Süddeutsche Zeitung in Zusammenarbeit mit hunderten Partnern die Paradise Papers.
Darin wurde aufgedeckt, dass etliche Konzerne, Milliardäre und sogar Politiker...
...und Regierungschefs überall auf der Welt Steuern vermeiden.
Gut, solange es legal ist, ne?
Ganz ehrlich, solange das legal ist, man kann sich da mit Sicherheit drüber streiten, ob das moralisch alles okay ist, ja.
Aber so wirklich übel nehmen kann ich das keinem.
Weil wenn ich mir überlege, wohin meine Steuern fließen und dass das in der Regel nicht das ist, was ich mir wünschen würde, was damit passiert.
Hey, wenn ich die Kohle hätte und die Möglichkeiten, dann würde ich das auch machen.
Solange es legal ist, ja.
Schreibung.
In den Paradise Papers ging es unter anderem auch um Nike.
Anfang der 2000er begann der Konzern mit der amerikanischen Rechtskanzlei Appleby zusammenzuarbeiten.
Nike wollte weltweit weniger Steuern zahlen, Appleby wusste wie.
Gemeinsam entwickelten sie ein raffiniertes Modell.
So gut wie alle Geschäfte von Nike innerhalb Europas werden über die Niederlande abgewickelt.
Ah, macht AliExpress ja auch.
Aber aus anderen Gründen.
Aus Jordan's Gönne kauft man die Schuhe eigentlich von einer niederländischen Firma in Hilversum.
In Deutschland werden also theoretisch fast keine Schuhe verkauft.
Die Nike-Stores dienen nur als Vermittler.
Ein großer Teil der Nike-Gewinne innerhalb Europas fließt also in die Niederlande.
Aber das ist nämlich die Endstation.
2005 gründet Nike mehrere Firmen auf den Bermudas.
Diesen Firmen überträgt Nike extrem viele Lizenzen.
Und Markenrechte.
Unter anderem auch den Swoosh.
Die Nike-Firmen auf der Inselgruppe dürfen fortan Lizenzen für das Aussehen der Schuhe verkaufen.
Der Käufer ist eine weitere niederländische Firma.
Okay, okay.
Nur dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Nike hat die Rechte an dem Design der Schuhe an eine Firma auf den Bermudas verkauft.
Und lizenziert sich jetzt quasi das Recht.
Ihre eigenen Schuhe zu designen zurück von der Firma auf den Bermudas.
Ah ja.
Werden Lizenzgebühren zu dieser Zeit nicht versteuert.
Seitdem fließen Milliarden aus der EU über die Niederlande auf die Bermudas.
Hier müssen Gewinne aus dem Ausland nicht versteuert werden.
In der EU bleibt ein deutlich kleinerer Gewinn übrig, weil die Lizenzgebühren so hoch sind.
Die zu zahlenden Steuern sind im Verhältnis zu den eigentlichen Einnahmen wahnsinnig niedrig.
Diese Strategie hat Nike größtenteils bis 2014 verfolgt.
Der Steuersatz, den das Unternehmen weltweit insgesamt auf seine Gewinne zahlt, ist so damals auf knapp 25% gefallen.
Die Jahre zuvor lag er durchschnittlich bei knapp 35%.
Ha!
Zeitweise wurden unversteuerte Gewinne...
Musst du dir mal überlegen!
25%?!
Ich bezahl was, weiß ich!
60% oder so!
Keine Ahnung!
Das meiste, was man bezahlen kann, muss ich bezahlen, ey!
Ist das wirklich fair?
Ist das mal ernsthaft?
...über 10 Milliarden US-Dollar in Steueroasen.
Ich meine, die Antwort ist, nein, ist es nicht, aber...
Dabei gab es auf den Bermudas weder Nike-Fabriken, noch Nike-Stores, noch Nike-Mitarbeiter.
Die Niederlande haben dieses Konstrukt von Nike mutmaßlich durch mehrere Deals begünstigt.
Die EU-Kommission hat Anfang 2019 deshalb offiziell eine Ermittlung gestartet.
Darin geht es um genau diese Deals.
Im Zeitraum zwischen 2006 und 2015.
Die von dem Land genehmigten Lizenzgebühren würden laut EU-Kommission nicht der wirtschaftlichen Realität entsprechen.
Nike soll dadurch einen ungerechten Wettbewerbsvorteil erhalten haben.
2014 werden viele der Unternehmen auf den Bermudas plötzlich aufgelöst.
Vermutlich, weil die Vereinbarungen mit den Niederlanden auslaufen.
Also muss ein neues Steuermodell her, das nicht abhängig von den Bermudas ist.
Diesmal bekommt Nike auch Hilfe von der amerikanischen Kanzlei Baker-McKenzie.
In den Niederlanden wird eine neue Firma namens Nike Innovate gegründet.
Da sind die richtigen Big-Plane-Stonks-Leute am Start.
Da werden die Lizenzen dort gehortet.
Das Geld fließt fortan aus dem EU-Ausland in die bestehenden niederländischen Firmen.
Und von dort über Lizenzgebühren in die Nike Innovate.
Das Besondere an der Nike Innovate ist die Art der Firma.
Sie ist nämlich eine sogenannte Gründung.
Also eine sogenannte Kommanditäre Vernutzrapp, kurz CV.
Und diese Art von Firma wird in den Niederlanden nicht besteuert.
Besteuert wird nur ihr General Partner, also quasi ihr Besitzer.
Folgt man den Besitzern der Nike Innovate CV, findet man zunächst einen Haufen weiterer CVs.
Der finale Besitzer dieser Kette an Firmen sitzt in den USA und heißt Nike Holding.
Die Tochter der Hauptfirma.
Da fliegt doch keine Sauber durch.
Nike Incorporated.
In den USA sind die CVs Tochterunternehmen von Nike im Ausland.
Und damit in den Niederlanden steuerpflichtig.
In den Niederlanden ist der General Partner in den USA steuerpflichtig.
Dadurch zahlt Nike einfach in keinem dieser beiden Länder Steuern.
Das freut Nike.
Das ist natürlich eine gute Taktik.
Der Steuersatz fällt von 2014 bis 2017 bis auf deutlich unter 15.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung. Was ist denn aktuell der Spitzensteuersatz in Deutschland?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel es ist.
42 Prozent. Okay.
Ernsthaft. Ich muss 42 Prozent bezahlen.
Oder 43 Prozent. Was auch immer.
Und Nike bezahlt 15 Prozent.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
15 Prozent. Ist das fair?
Nö.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Hätte ich die Kohle, hätte ich die Möglichkeiten und wäre das legal, würde ich das auch so machen.
Weil ich bin es leid, so viel Steuern zu bezahlen.
Für Dinger, wo nicht das gemacht wird, was ich gerne hätte.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich bin der korrekteste aller korrekten Typen, wenn es darum geht, Sachen anzugeben.
Also bei mir ist, ich gebe nichts, nichts an.
Also ich habe alles, sowas von genau immer drin.
Da kann, da kann keiner irgendwas machen.
Deswegen, solange das legal ist, würde ich das auch so machen.
Geld verdienen dürfen.
Und dem Gemeinwesen dann so wenig zurückgeben müssen.
Das Unternehmen nutzt unsere Infrastruktur und hat in Europa tausende Angestellte.
Max Innovate in den Niederlanden. Gute Idee.
Die an teils öffentlich finanzierten Unis ausgebildet wurden.
Und es freut sich sicherlich über belebte, sichere Innenstädte, in denen der Deutsche gerne und häufig shoppen geht.
Also alle regen sich über Ungerechtigkeit, Ungleichheit, unmoralisches Verhalten.
Die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich.
Die reichen die Apples dieser Welt auf.
Anstatt konkret zu überlegen, was muss ich denn ändern?
Das ist Dr. Irina Kummert, Präsidentin des Ethikverbandes der deutschen Wirtschaft.
Wir haben ein Ethikverband der deutschen Wirtschaft.
Wir haben sie gefragt, ob eine Art globales Steuersystem in solchen Fällen helfen könnte.
Also sie müssten im Grunde genommen alle an einen Tisch kriegen.
Und da würde ich jetzt fast mal wetten, dass das kaum funktioniert.
Weil eben diese jeweiligen landeseigenen Interessen da im Vordergrund stehen.
Länder haben nämlich ein Interesse daran, große internationale Konzerne zu beheimaten.
Das erschwert es den Behörden allerdings, gegen Schlupflöcher und Steuertricks vorzugehen.
Laut der Hilfs- und Entwicklungsorganisation Oxfam sind die Niederlande, Irland, Luxemburg und Malta die Steueroasen Europas.
Ja, Luxemburg ist Amazon am Start.
Und sie haben verschiedene EU-Richtlinien, die Steuertricks wie die von Nike künftig verhindern sollen.
Sogenannte hybride Gestaltungen, die Unterschiede zwischen EU und EU-Ausland ausnutzen, sind künftig nicht mehr erlaubt.
Klingt schon mal hybride Gestaltung.
Bis Ende 2021 müssen EU-Mitglieder, darunter natürlich auch die Niederlande, diese Richtlinie umsetzen.
Auch die OECD versucht, härter gegen Steuervermeidung vorzugehen.
Einige Maßnahmen haben dazu geführt, dass ferne Steueroasen wie die Cayman Islands,
die Bermudas oder Panama weniger genutzt werden.
Im Fall Nike sind die USA der EU allerdings zuvorgekommen.
2017 gab es eine Steuerreform.
Für US-Unternehmen wurde das komplizierte Gebilde aus Firmen in den Niederlanden auf einen Schlag unattraktiv.
Unter anderem deshalb musste Nike 2018 2,4 Milliarden Dollar Steuern zahlen.
Das entsprach einem Steuersatz von 55,5 Milliarden Dollar.
2020 lag der Steuersatz für Nike allerdings wieder nur bei 12,1 Prozent.
Haben sie wieder was gefunden?
War er noch nie.
Das hängt auch wiederum mit der erwähnten US-Steuerreform von 2017 zusammen.
Außerdem konnte Nike durch aktienbasierte Vergütungen einiges an Steuern sparen.
Das im Detail zu erklären, würde hier allerdings zu weit fühlen.
Allein Deutschland gehen jährlich geschätzt 17 Milliarden Euro,
durch Steueroasen und Steuertricks verloren.
Das entspricht ungefähr den Ausgaben für das Bildungssystem.
Die Corona-Pandemie kostet Deutschland hunderte Milliarden Euro.
Es gibt deutlich mehr Arbeitslose.
Millionen von Menschen beziehen Kurzarbeitergeld.
Die Armut in Deutschland ist seit der Wiedervereinigung auf einem historischen Höchststand.
Jeder Staat muss diese Menschen auffangen und unterstützen.
All das kreiert hohe Kosten,
die zumindest in Teilen über Steuergelder gedeckt werden müssen.
Momentan ist es also besonders bitter, wenn Konzerne,
die vom Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland extrem profitieren,
ihren Beitrag nicht zahlen.
Chapeau an großartige Investigativ-Recherchen,
wie die der Süddeutschen Zeitung und ihren Partnern.
Sie kreieren den notwendigen Druck und die Aufmerksamkeit,
um gegen die Steuermachenschaft,
einiger Weltkonzerne vorzugehen.
Die Sache ist halt die,
dazu muss erstmal an der richtigen Stelle,
also es bringt ja nichts, wenn sich die Bevölkerung da irgendwie aufregt,
dazu muss erstmal an der richtigen Stelle der Willen da sein,
dazu was zu machen, äh dagegen was zu machen.
Neben Nike nutzen zum Beispiel auch Apple, Amazon und Facebook
seit Jahren jedes mögliche Schlupfloch.
Egal ob Steueroasen, intransparente Konstrukte oder etliche Briefkastenfirmen.
Sie haben das nötige Geld und die Marktmacht,
um jede legale Möglichkeit in Betracht zu ziehen.
Jede Grauzone auszuschaffen.
Leute, überlegt euch mal, diese Beraterfirma,
die mit Nike das aufgebaut hat,
was meint ihr, was die für eine Wahnsinnskohle dafür bekommen hat?
Weil letztendlich haben die sich ja komplett selbst bezahlt.
Die müssen so viel weniger Steuern bezahlen,
die können Millionen an diese Beratungsfirma zahlen
und es ist immer noch billiger.
Das wirkt auf einige vielleicht smart und raffiniert und...
Patrick, ich hab's grad gesagt, ohne Scheiß,
wenn ich das Geld hätte, die Möglichkeiten und das legal ist,
ich würde das auch machen.
Tja, dann darf man sich als Unternehmen halt im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes asozial verhalten.
Langsame Behörden haben es schwer, großen Konzernen auf die Spur zu kommen.
Länder konkurrieren um große Unternehmen und geben ihnen Orte,
und geben ihnen oft sogar Sonderbehandlungen.
Es gibt zu viele Interessenkonflikte und es mangelt an Koordinierung und Transparenz.
Darunter leidet am Ende die breite Gesellschaft.
Ihr bleibt den Versagt, mit dem man zum Beispiel bessere Bildungsmöglichkeiten schaffen kann.
Da hat er recht. Man könnte allerdings,
man könnte allerdings, da kann man sich jetzt prinzipiell wieder drüber aufregen,
machen wir jetzt aber nicht,
man könnte auch das Geld, was man hat, vielleicht mal an sinnvolleren Stellen ausgeben.
Das Beispiel für Breitbandausbau.
Naja, könnte, wenn die Steuern denn gezahlt werden würden.
Tja.
Cheers.
Da hat er schon recht. Da hat er schon recht.
So.
Gucken wir uns als nächstes an.
Was ist Breitband? Ja, ist unbekannt hier. Neuland.
Venice Unleashed Airstrike Mod.
Was sieht, wie sieht es da eigentlich aus?
Gibt es nichts Neues.
Gibt es nichts Neues, oder?
About.
Forum.
Announcements.
Nope.
Twitter.
Gibt es irgendwas Neues?
Wer das nicht kennt, das ist ein Battlefield 3 Modpack,
die quasi Battlefield 3 modbar gemacht haben,
mit Custom Server und man kann Blaufilter entfernen,
man kann eigene Mods machen.
Also es ist, es besteht zumindest eine kleine Chance,
dass Battlefield 3 damit wieder ein bisschen beliebter wird.
Wenn das denn rauskommt.
Angeblich kommt es Ende des Jahres raus.
Das Lock Picking Video, okay.
Ja, das ist immer gut.
Ah, yes.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
So.
Oh.
Okay.
Einfach durchschneiden.
Moment, warte, warte, warte.
Das ist eine Kammer, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Man kann damit ein Bild von innen im Schloss machen?
Ja, das ist besser, ne?
What the fuck?
Was es alles gibt?
Big Brain, ja.
Das funktioniert!
Das ist ja geil.
Okay, da ist der erste Slider.
Das scheint ein 1x1.
Ich sollte bemerken, dass wenn ihr diese Bilder später spüren wollt,
einfach den Knopf drücken.
Und die Bilder sind gespeichert für euer Telefon.
Der nächste Slider scheint ein 5x1 zu sein.
Der nächste ist ein 1x1.
Aha, ich weiß zwar nicht, was das bedeutet, aber alles klar.
Jetzt haben wir einen 4x1.
Und der letzte ist ein 5x1.
Also, die Knöpfe für diesen Schloss sind 1x5, 1x4, 5.
Was kann ich damit machen?
Nun, in einem Klick kann ich eine Klammer bekommen.
Eine Klammer, eine Klammer-Gage und eine Klammer.
Und eine neue Klammer.
Aber ich habe gerade eine spezielle Maschine in meinem Garage,
die für die Klammer von diesen Nummern hergestellt ist.
Also, lasst uns da runter und probieren.
Okay, Leute, ich bin in meinem Garage mit meiner HPC-Klips-Maschine.
Ist der Typ eigentlich wirklich Anwalt?
Oder heißt der Channel nur so?
... Maschine, die in meiner Meinung die Gold-Standarde ist,
wenn es um die Klammer-Orginierung geht.
Das ist die Klammer, um Quick-Set-Klips zu schneiden.
Und ich werde einen KW-1-Blank in die Klammer stecken.
Ich werde jetzt mein Bestes tun, um eine Klammer sicher zu schneiden,
während ich mit dem Tripod arbeite.
Wieso hat man sowas daheim?
Ja, weil es der Lockpicking-Lawyer ist.
Aha, aha.
Man sieht doch überhaupt nicht, was man macht.
Oder kapiere ich die Maschine?
Ich glaube, ich kapiere die Maschine nicht.
Ach doch, hier unten.
Ach, und hier sieht man, wie weit man reingeschliffen hat.
Oder so wahrscheinlich.
Ah.
Ah!
Okay, also mit den Rädchen.
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Hiermit stellt man quasi ein, wie weit der Schlüssel reingeht.
Und auf welcher Achse der Schlüssel ist.
Und hier auf den Karten muss man im Endeffekt nur gucken,
dass man das dort positioniert,
was man vorher mit der Kamera abfotografiert hat.
Ah ja, okay, okay.
Must-have brauche ich auch.
Ne, brauche ich nicht.
Das ist ein Thema, was mich nicht großartig interessiert.
Aber es ist nice zu sehen, was es so gibt.
Okay.
Schlüssel fertig. Easy.
Ah, jetzt wird das Ganze nochmal ordentlich poliert.
Dazu kann man nur sagen.
Easy.
Das coole ist.
Überlegt euch mal.
Du gehst einfach irgendwo hin.
Machst ein Bild vom Schloss.
Gehst wieder heim.
Machst einen Schlüssel.
Gehst nächsten Tag vorbei und machst Schloss auf.
Das ist eigentlich super easy.
Gut, ich meine, man muss es können, ja.
Aber eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Ja.
Genau.
Ah ja.
Leute, die sowas machen,
die geben da auch 300 Dollar für aus.
Ja, meine ich doch so auf Jelly.
Wenn du irgendwo so ein Schloss hängen siehst,
dann gehst du hin,
machst dieses Ding rein,
machst ein Foto, gehst heim, fertigst den Schlüssel an,
danach gehst du vorbei, machst Schloss auf.
...
... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ... ...
Ja, das ist eine Skamars-App. Man muss ja sagen, man würde ja davon ausgehen, dass die Sachen, die im App-Store sind, also im Chrome-Store und im Firefox-Addon-Store, dass die in irgendeiner Art und Weise kontrolliert sind.
Sind sie auch, aber recht, recht lasch, ja. Ich hatte auch schon mal das Problem, dass ich einen Addon installiert habe, wo ich dann einen Monat später rausbekommen habe, das wurde an irgendwelche Chinesen verkauft und man sollte schleunig deinstallieren.
Was es stattdessen war, war ein Survey, also es war nur ein Programm, das versucht hat, dass man Surveys füllen kann, um einige deiner persönlichen Informationen zu bekommen.
Es hat keine Funktionalität gegeben, es ist sicherlich nichts, was Apple angeht.
Das hat Apple entwickelt, aber das hat nicht die Leute verhindert, die FaceTime-Name und Logo in manchen Fällen zu benutzen und versucht hat, diese Chrome-Web-App als offizielle Apple-App zu entwerfen.
Nun, in diesem Video, bis zum Ende, habe ich ein ganz anderes Knochenwurm bemerkt, das wir heute machen werden, und das ist Snapchat für PC.
Und wie in der Falle von FaceTime für Chrome, haben wir mehr als eine dieser.
Sie können sehen, ich habe hier fünf Tabs geöffnet.
Und ich glaube,
es gibt noch mehr, und wir werden in all diesen, zumindest diese fünf, in diesem Video sprechen.
Nun, Snapchat ist nicht auf Windows oder Mac OS X oder irgendeinem Desktop-Operationssystem verfügbar.
Es ist nur auf iOS und Android verfügbar.
Also, deine beste Chance, Snapchat auf Windows zu funktionieren, ist,
diese Chat-Geschichte, die dadurch bekannt geworden ist und Verbreitung gefunden hat, dass die Leute darüber ihre Dick-Pics schicken können, die man angeblich nur einmal angucken kann oder die man angeblich nach einem gewissen Zeitraum wieder löschen kann, oder?
Das ist doch das mit diesen Einweg-Nachrichten und angeblich verfallenden Nachrichten und sonst was in der Richtung.
Das ist ja das, mit dem Snapchat irgendwie groß geworden ist, oder?
Das bringe ich jetzt nicht durcheinander, ne?
Das ist quasi die...
Die Dick-Pic-App für Jugendliche heutzutage.
Okay.
Das ist auch die App, wo sie sich ultra drüber aufgeregt haben, als das Look und Feel geändert wurde.
Was ich übrigens auch immer wieder erschreckend finde, ist,
ich bin ja eigentlich davon ausgegangen, wo ich in dem Alter war, wo man quasi heute Snapchat verwendet,
ich bin davon ausgegangen, dass, wenn ich mal in dem Alter bin, wie ich heute bin,
dass dann die Leute, die quasi in dem Alter sind, wo ich damals war,
dass die, was technische Sachen angeht, etwas bessere Vorbildungen haben als damals, ja?
Damals war das alles noch recht neu.
Heute hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, jeder kann das.
Und da wundert es mich zum Beispiel, dass keiner auf die glorische Idee kommt,
naja, sobald du es bei dir auf dem Bildschirm anzeigen lassen kannst, gerade wenn es ein Android-Gerät ist,
kannst du davon auch einen Screenshot machen.
Ja, man kann das blocken, aber man kann das Blocken auch entblocken.
Und im Zweifelsfall machst du irgendeine Screen-Capture oder sonst irgendwelche Dinger, ja?
Also, sobald du es auf dem Bildschirm anzeigen kannst, kannst du auch einen Screenshot machen.
Sobald du es anzeigen kannst, kannst du es auch speichern.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommt, dass das irgendwie sicher wäre.
Naja, egal, egal. Gucken wir mal weiter.
Das ist irgendein Scam.
Aber guck mal, es haben schon 50.000 Downloads.
Hier, 50.000 schon mal Downloads.
Und ich frage mich, wie es überhaupt auf 1, fast 2 Sterne kommt.
Also, wie bei der FaceTime-App, haben sie hier einige Dinge gemacht, um dich zu überzeugen,
dass das tatsächlich von Snapchat entwickelt wird.
Es ist Snapchat für PC.
Du hast das offizielle Logo.
Hier, es sagt Offered by Snapchat.
Irgendwie, ich meine, ich glaube, die Chrome-Webstore hat nicht wirklich...
Ja, Nike, Felix, genau das meine ich.
Und da bin ich eigentlich von ausgegangen, dass Leute heutzutage sowas durchschauen,
dass das eben einfach nur Sprüche sind, ohne was dahinter.
Und jeder, der Sachen speichern, Screenshotten, sonst was will, kann es einfach tun.
Aber anscheinend sind die Leute heute auch nicht schlauer geworden.
...Restriktionen auf die Namen, die man als Entwickler benutzen kann.
Was wirklich problematisch ist, weil das 50.000...
Das ist das, was ich gerade am Anfang gesagt habe.
Warum kann sich jeder Kacknub, der da hergelaufen ist, im Chrome-Store Snapchat nennen?
...über 50.000 Leute, dass das eine offizielle App entwickelt wurde von Snapchat...
Ja, das wundert mich nicht. 90% der Leute sind halt einfach dumm.
...für Chrome.
Aber die Reviews geben wirklich das eine weg.
130 Reviews mit einem Anzahl von 1,6 aus 5 Sternen.
Und wenn wir hier runterklicken, haben wir dieses eine Bild.
Und auch, wenn du das mit Justin Bieber vergleichst, was wir auf der App-Store haben,
dann gibt es viel mehr Informationen.
...wenn es hier ist, also das sollte ein weiteres großes Angebot sein.
Und auch das größte Angebot aller Dingen ist, dass Snapchat nicht durch Google Chrome laufen kann.
Es ist seine eigene App.
Es kann nicht in einem Chrome-Webstore-App laufen.
Und es ist sicher nicht 8,63 Kibibyte in Größe.
Außerdem wurde es im letzten Jahr über ein Jahr ago berücksichtigt, am September 22, 2019.
Das ist beziehungsweise Version 5.0.2.
Bevor wir diese Sache installieren, möchte ich kurz auf die Reviews schauen.
Weil das ist kind of what I was...
It sucks, okay es ist irgendein Werbespam.
Ja, jetzt wird die das großartig jucken bei Google.
Edge? Es ist Edge? Monker S.
Fullyfaster.com slash Snapchat. Oh ja. Und jetzt sollst du irgendwie ein Virus downloaden, oder wie?
Da sind wie Eier auf dem Geistercharakter jetzt.
Also klickst du drauf, bekommst du ein paar HTML-Codes.
Noch nicht mal der Scheiß funktioniert.
Okay, was ist das? Ist das nur ein APK-File? Ist das alles?
Ja, sieh 65.11. Ja, das ist ein APK-File.
Moment, das ist eine Chrome-Extension zum Downloaden von Snap...
Was?
Das ist alles.
Also, ich meine, du würdest nicht...
Ich würde nicht...
Ich würde nicht empfehlen, Snapchat von nichts außer der Google Play Store zu downloaden.
Ja, auch nicht.
Aber du kannst...
Du weißt, es ist sehr einfach...
Okay, und was, und was genau bezwecken die jetzt mit der App?
Trackt das irgendwelche Sachen?
Ich meine, irgendwas müssen die ja davon haben.
... APKs auf deinem Android-Gehäuse.
Aber du kannst das nicht auf Windows nativieren.
Ich meine, du kannst, wie gesagt, Bluestacks oder so etwas verwenden.
Aber, äh, das ist nicht nötig für Windows-Computer.
Also, das funktioniert nicht.
Aber du hast hier all diese, so, Ads drauf.
Es geht nicht um...
Nein, ich gehe nicht auf die Seite.
Ähm, auch nicht in der VM.
Weil ich weiß nicht, was für Images da drauf sind.
Vielleicht ist da heute irgendwelchen Porn drauf.
Und wenn ich das im Stream zeige, ist es mal ein Kartoffel.
... es gibt wahrscheinlich einige...
Du weißt, es wird wahrscheinlich etwas daraus kommen.
Weil ich sicher bin, dass Leute auf diese Ads klicken.
Und sie könnten etwas Geld machen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber es ist sicherlich...
Es ist sicherlich nicht Snapchat.
Es ist nicht Snapchat.
Also, lasst uns hier ein paar von diesen anderen nehmen.
Dieser hier, bin mir ziemlich sicher, ist genau der gleiche wie der, den wir gerade gesehen haben.
Sieht ja auch schon exakt genau so aus.
... weil ich es zufällig verwirrt habe.
Ja, das ist es.
Das ist genau das gleiche.
Ich habe tatsächlich in einer vorherigen Ausgabe geklickt.
Ich wollte auf diesen Tab klicken.
Und ich habe stattdessen auf diesen geklickt.
Es hat genau das gleiche Bild.
Und die gleiche Beschreibung.
Aber nochmals, wir haben hier etwas seltsames.
Mit der File-Version.
Die File-Size ist anders.
Eigentlich, nein, nicht dieses Mal.
Es ist genau das gleiche.
Okay.
Das ist 5.0.
Das ist 4.0.
Alles klar.
Aber dieser ist etwas neuer.
Er wurde letztens am Oktober 20 geupdatet.
Also ungefähr ein Monat nach diesem.
Aber es ist Version 4.0.2 anstatt 5.0.2.
Boah.
Also, wir gehen weiter mit diesem.
Ich meine, es ist so schwer, diese aufzuhalten.
Weil sie alle Snapchat nennen.
Das sieht ja äußerst vertrauenswert aus hier.
... für PC.
Also, dieser hier hat genau das gleiche Bild.
Ist das...
Oh, wir haben ein anderes Bild hier.
Snapchat auf PC.
Schau dir das an.
Ist das nicht großartig?
8,63 KB.
Ich glaube, das ist genau das gleiche.
Und ja, das ist es.
Das ist wundervoll.
Also, du hast drei Applikationen...
Was ist das?
... die genau das gleiche machen.
Warum gibt es drei verschiedene Applikationen dafür?
Es ist einfach...
Naja, wahrscheinlich gibt es drei verschiedene Applikationen, falls Google mal eins löscht.
Oh Gott.
Und schau dir das an.
Es ist das gleiche.
Oh mein Gott.
Okay.
Das ist verrückt.
Ich meine, es ist wie eine Sache, eine Applikation in einem Laden zu haben.
Aber vier der identischen Applikationen in einem Laden zu haben, das ist noch verrückter.
Sie haben noch mehr Chancen, herauszufinden, dass...
Vor allem, die Extension ist auch noch kaputt, wenn man oben drauf klickt.
... die Applikationen falsch sind.
Aber das sind nicht alle.
Also, jetzt, dass ich diese installiert habe, wird es für alle, die ich bekommen habe,
zusätzlich genutzt werden.
Oh, guck mal.
Mehr von diesem Entwickler...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der einzige Entwickler ist, der den Namen Snapchat auf dem ganzen
Laden benutzt.
Aber sie haben zwei mehr, die ich noch nicht installiert habe.
Oh ja, das sieht auch äußerst vertrauenserweckend aus.
Das ist ein anderes Icon.
Das ist ziemlich schlecht.
Es ist wie...
Diese Bildung...
Die Bildung ist eine Stock-Bildung des Backlit-Keyboards auf einem MacBook.
Und dann hast du dieses seltsame Logo drüben.
Ich meine, das sind nur zwei Bilder, die zusammengefasst werden in Photoshop oder so.
Das ist genau das gleiche File Size.
Ich werde es mir nicht interessieren, es zu installieren.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Was haben wir hier?
Wir haben dieses hier.
Oder...
Oh, guck mal.
Drei-Sterne-Bewertung.
Dieses hier hat 2.000 Benutzer.
Und, oh, dieses hier sagt...
Dieser hier sagt Fishing-App.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Ich meine, ich bin sicher, dass es das gleiche ist.
Es ist.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht ist es...
Weil...
Wenn du hier auf diesen Link klickst, öffnet es einen kleinen URL-Link und dann führst
du dich einfach zu diesem hier.
Also, vielleicht war eine ältere Version von diesem eine Fishing-App.
Aber wir haben hier noch mehr.
Also, lass mich versuchen, zu finden.
Ich meine, ich werde nur die mit diesem Logo vermeiden.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Meine Meinung ist, dass sie alle gleich sein werden.
Also, was ist das?
Snapchat für Chrome.
Bei Chrome.
Moment.
Ey, das ist doch mal Fail von Google, oder?
Es ist doch nicht mal verboten, sich Chrome zu...
Also...
Chrome als Hersteller zu benutzen im Chrome-Job.
Warum ist das erlaubt?
Google ist echt Monarch S, ja.
Ey.
Sonst ist Google auch übelst pingelig, was das angeht.
Aber hier, es juckt die überhaupt nicht.
Ja, auch installiert.
Zehntausend User.
Bam, bam, bam.
Das Logo.
Das erinnert mich an dieses... an dieses... an dieses Ghost-Stock-Image, was ich bei Call
of Duty Ghosts manchmal durchs Bild hab fliegen lassen.
Das sah ungefähr genauso schlecht aus.
Snapchat-Logo hier.
Let's see.
So.
Fortnite, alles klar, exzellent.
You must verify your account, please complete one of the offers, alles klar.
Oh Gott, es ist...
Okay, wenigstens versuchen sie noch nicht mal Passwörter abzugreifen.
Sondern machen Werbungsscams.
Maybe this is made by the same person, because this is identical to the FaceTime...
Guck dir mal die Logos da oben an, ey.
Das ist eine richtig gute Videoidee.
Das schreibe ich dir mal auf.
Scam.
Google Chrome Scam Addons.
Muss mal sein, ne.
Except for the fact that it, you know, has the FaceTime image in the background.
It actually has a password box.
This one, for whatever reason, doesn't have a password box.
How would you be able to sign into an account without a password?
So I can put anything here or nothing, as you just saw.
And it does the same thing.
It authentically...
Yeah, gut, es ist halt...
Wenigstens greifen sie keine User-Accounts ab.
...which I'm not going to go through, because they are surveys that are probably scams.
I would not recommend going through them at all.
So, that's this one.
Then we've...
I mean, look at all of these.
Warum gibt es da so viele?
Also, ich finde es echt heftig, dass man sich im App-Store einfach Chrome und Snapchat nennen darf.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht.
...die Scam-Applications von der Chrome-Web-Store.
Du hast...
Ich meine, dieses hier sagt, dass du Snapchat-Accounts hacken kannst.
Alles klar.
Oh!
Moment, Moment.
...Chat-Accounts.
Bestes Logo, Alter.
Wahnsinnige Photoshop-Skills.
Really?
Du denkst, dass du das machen wirst?
Und...
Oh, und hier ist ein Typ, der versucht, vielleicht noch ein Fake-Tool zu promoten,
und sagt, dass das Fake ist, aber das ist echt.
Das ist ja auch geil.
Scheiß-Tool, nehmt meins, was genauso Scam ist.
Oh, Mann.
Dazu würde ich auch ein Video machen.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Reihe von Applikationen, weil es so viele gibt.
Leute, wenn euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr mehr davon sehen wollt,
dann gebt diesem Video definitiv einen Daumen nach oben.
Seid sicher, dass ihr euch abonniere.
Und drückt die Glocke.
Und klickt die Kanal-Notifikation, wenn ihr es noch nicht getan habt,
um die Notifikationen zu bekommen, wenn ich ein neues Video veröffentliche,
das ich mehrere Male pro Woche auf diesem Kanal mache.
Und wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der Snapchat für PC oder FaceTime für Chrome veröffentlicht hat,
dann lasst sie es uns wissen.
Teilt dieses Video mit ihnen.
Scam-Boss.
...wie diese Art von Scams vorhanden sind,
und dass sie auf der Suche nach den Applikationen sind, die sie veröffentlicht haben,
um sicherzustellen, dass sie nicht nur Scams veröffentlicht haben,
sondern auch Surveys für Dinge, die sie nicht brauchen.
Und macht sicher, dass sie wissen, dass diese Art von Scams vorhanden sind,
und dass es nicht möglich ist, Snapchat oder FaceTime auf Google Chrome zu nutzen.
Und wenn ihr noch andere seltsame, bizarre Chrome-Webstore-Applikationen habt,
die ihr mir auf diesem Kanal anschauen möchtet,
dann lasst mir einen Kommentar da unten.
Ich glaube, da mache ich auch ein Video dazu.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Ich suche mir die krassesten Scam-Apps in Chrome raus und zeige die.
Ich meine, letztendlich ist es ja easy.
Ich mache einfach eine VM.
Am besten auch eine Linux-VM.
Da kann ja gar nichts passieren.
Dann ist gut.
Ich schicke Snapchat-Accounts in 2021.
Ja, manche Überschriften sind schon...
Das sieht schon so legit aus alles, ja.
Genau, Kali-Linux-VM.
Dann macht das auch schon so einen richtig krassen Hacker-Man-Eindruck.
Ja, interessant, was sie alles gibt.
So.
Ähm...
Das Video habe ich schon geguckt.
Das fand ich eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Irgendjemand ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
und hat eine Visual Studio Code Tinder-Extension programmiert.
Eigentlich eine richtig witzige Idee, ja.
Ich wollte mich da eigentlich schon just for fun mal anmelden
und gucken, was so alles drin ist.
Wahrscheinlich funktioniert das wieder nicht
und die Leute posten irgendwelche Dick-Ascii-Arts oder sowas.
Aber die Idee ist schon mal echt big brain.
Welfi, top.
Welfi, top place.
Battlefield Bad Company 3 League.
Nein, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was ist ein Boomer-Shooter?
Excellent.
Just for fun.
Ja, tatsächlich, just for fun.
Also, einfach nur mal zu gucken.
Ich meine, das ist ja nichts, was wirklich funktionieren wird, ja.
Aber die Idee fand ich witzig.
Ja, VS Code Stories hat er ja verkauft.
Custom Wasserkühlung für 70 Euro AliExpress.
Alles klar.
Komm, wir gucken das jetzt mal.
Ich habe das Video zwar schon geguckt,
aber ich finde die Idee, ich finde die Idee echt gut.
Brought to you by the ex-founder of VS Code Stories,
we have a dating app designed specifically for developers.
The conventional dating app focuses on physical appearance.
But after doing some extensive market research,
I found that developers also want people to be smart.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das ist tatsächlich so.
Die meisten Menschen gehen mir auf den Sack,
weil sie einfach dumm sind.
Das war doof zu sagen.
Also, gegen ein bisschen, bisschen, bisschen Leute mit Brain,
ist ja nichts einzuhören.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Darf man das überhaupt noch schreiben?
... be swiping on these bodies.
This is a real VS Code extension that I made.
And if you go to the extensions and search for VSender,
you should be able to find it.
I know it says no extensions found.
Ich würde eher sagen, es heißt VS Inder.
... because I haven't deployed it yet.
But when you're watching this, it will be deployed.
And don't fret if you don't use VS Code.
I got a special surprise for those of you at the end.
Because I know there are some Notepad++ users out there
that are single and really need this.
So I'm looking out for you.
Before we do...
Genau, mach noch eine Notepad++-Extension.
Let me show you how it actually works.
So when you install the extension,
there's going to be a new icon on the left right here.
Well, maybe at the bottom, I don't know.
I move it to the top because, you know.
So here we go.
You click on it, it's the heart.
And the first thing you're going to need to do is log in.
And I did not...
And I did not do anonymous this time.
I learned my lesson.
So I'm going to log in.
After logging with GitHub...
Der hat ja letztens schon mal
eine Visual Studio Code Extension gemacht.
Da konnte man Bilder hochladen.
Und die Leute haben halt Porn und Dickpics
und alles ohne Ende hochgeladen.
Und er hat halt schon gesagt,
er macht nie wieder eine Extension,
wo die Leute Bilder hochladen können.
... authorize it,
then you're going to be redirected to a success screen
and then you're good to go.
You hop back over the VS Code
and now you have basically a little form over here.
So this is your profile.
It's going to autofill the name,
in the bio.
And we're just going to fill out this form real quick.
So I'm going to just set the name to Ben.
This is the display name that everyone's going to see.
I'm going to keep my bio.
You can add a flare.
A couple of different options.
Ich brauche mal ein C-Sharp-Flare.
Show off your personality.
And then you can set your age.
69.
Excellent.
To compute your age
and make sure it's always accurate.
So I'm going to set mine.
I'm 97.
97.
And I'm actually 23.
So let's pick a birthday.
It makes me 23.
Perfect.
So here you have two different options.
So if you were looking for love,
we have the love section.
And this is for 18 years and older.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher.
Der macht so die Hälfte macht er zum Trollen
und die andere Hälfte legit.
Or if you're just looking for friendship,
there's this section here
and you can just match to make friends basically.
So I'm looking for love.
So I'm going to press this here.
And then you can go out
and you can fill out these things.
I'm just going to click this,
keep the defaults
and I'm going to set my location here.
So I'm in Austin.
So I'm going to click that.
A quick note on the location.
So you don't have to specify your location
if you don't want to,
but you're going to be matched with users
based on location first.
I recommend checking this box
because this will like globally match you
with other users
if they didn't set their location.
But it's going to prioritize people
that are in Austin to me first.
All right.
So that's that.
And we're going to say next.
And this is instead of uploading images
of yourself,
we're going to be doing code instead.
So how this works is you can either,
you know, highlight some code in VS code.
So that's why I have my lovely
fizzbuzz program here that I'm very proud of.
So I'm going to highlight some code here
and I keep there just copy pastes
into the box here, right?
Or if I want to,
I have this handy dandy little button.
Also wenn das Programm
bei den hotten Programmergrills
keinen Eindruck macht,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
On the bottom right here
called the sender snippet.
I can click that
and I'll pop it in here.
Now note this limits
to 600 characters.
So if you put more,
it's just going to basically slice it off.
So just keep a note of that.
It also if you press this button,
it'll grab the language that you're using
if it knows the language.
Otherwise you can specify the syntax
if you want a different one going on here.
Also note there's auto.
Gibt es die?
Ja.
Sonst wäre die Extension überflüssig.
Then you can specify a theme
in a font family.
Ich meine, wo kann man denn sonst
sein Date danach auswählen?
Was ist für einen Editor,
Programmiersprache und Color Scheme
und Programmierfont verwendet?
Das ist genau das,
was die Welt gebraucht hat.
Play around and look at different themes
and see what they look like.
So I have this button here
called click to preview
where you can actually see
what it looks like.
Kobol, Kobol muss man.
Kobol und so ein richtig
old school Color Scheme.
Click over here
and this just takes you to Carbon.
So if you haven't heard of Carbon,
it's a really nice site
that lets you create images of code.
And that's what we're using
because I am not letting
you guys upload it.
We tried that.
Ja, da hat er schlechte Erfahrungen
mit seiner letzten Extension gemacht.
We're just going to do straight code
or straight text
and I will make the image through Carbon.
That's how I'm doing it anyway.
So you can try out different themes,
see which one you like.
And then I just clicked
on the same theme twice.
And when you find one that you like,
you can then go back
and then you can generate that.
So I'm going to come back over here.
I think I'm going to go
with a purple theme
since we're using Haskell.
So go shades of purple here.
And again, I can tweak
the font family,
but I'm just going to keep it.
Ganz wichtig.
Passende, passende
Font ausgewählt sein.
And then when that's done,
I can go ahead and save.
Also wenn das mal niemand überzeugt,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
It's a little bit slow sometimes
because we're using Serverless.
So you may get some cold starts.
So keep a note of that.
But you don't have to actually
wait for it to load.
You can just keep adding letters.
Leute, Leute.
Wisst ihr eigentlich,
dass Serverless
auch einfach nur Server sind?
Like goes.
Denkt mal drüber nach.
And then when you're happy
with the profile,
you can add up to six of these.
You can save it.
And you are done
basically setting up.
So if you want to,
you can click on your face here
and you can actually see your card.
So here is my bin card here.
Okay, let me show you
the fun part now.
So let's start swiping.
And these are what
the profiles look like.
Down here we have an X
and a heart button.
Das Geile ist halt,
dass es für dieses Ankündigungsvideo,
dass das alles gefaked ist.
Also es ist ja nicht wirklich so,
als wäre da Medi22 angemeldet.
Das sind einfach irgendwelche
hardcodete Profiles für die Demo.
Press X.
We never want to see
the profile again.
We don't like it.
Heart means we like it.
And this works like Tinder.
If I heart their profile
and they heart my profile,
we match and we start talking.
Excellent.
Or at least I'll show you
that in a second.
And then also
if you scroll down,
there is a report button.
So if this user
has anything inappropriate
in their profile,
you can report them here.
I will be checking this.
So report if you see anything weird.
And then you can also do
some keyboard shortcuts.
Like I don't want to be
coming down here
and press X and heart every time.
So if I press the left arrow key
or the right arrow key,
that'll swipe as well.
All right.
So yeah.
So here I can see their code.
I can see the name,
their age,
their flair,
their profile image.
And by the way,
I didn't mention this.
This is guaranteed
irgendein Stock,
irgendein Stock-Foto
für die Demo.
On GitHub.
Weil mal ganz im Ernst,
dass da wirklich viele,
also echte Grills sich anmelden,
halte ich doch
für recht unwahrscheinlich.
You can't deal with
the images whatsoever.
So I'm letting GitHub
post images
and deal with that.
And if you want
to change your image,
all you need to do
is change it on GitHub
and then load it
and then log out
down here
and re-log in.
But anyway,
let's start swiping here.
All right.
So we got Maddy up first.
If you call my.py
I'll overfill you with love.
No.
Oh,
ist das,
ist das Erlang?
Ist das Erlang?
Nee.
Lisp?
Was ist denn das?
Es ist entweder Erlang
oder Lisp.
Irgendwas,
irgendwas ekliges.
Irgendwas mit ganz
vielen Klammern.
Closure.
Oh,
ist ja fast das gleiche.
Also,
Render,
der hat ein Lisp.
Ja,
Lisp.
Okay,
komm,
get lost
in my parentheses.
Okay,
well like.
Mina
with some
CPP.
I,
C++.
CPP.
Hör' mal auf.
You have free primers
on primes
if you need
pointers.
All right,
all right.
I'll give that a like.
Das Geile ist,
wie er halt so tut,
als wären das echte Profile.
Also,
Das kann er gut verkaufen. Das sind halt alles Demo-Profile. Die gibt's gar nicht.
Oh, er hat eine Message. Also im Prinzip schreibt er gerade eine Message mit sich selbst.
Absolut nicht skriptet.
Was geht hier? Der Kerl hat eine Tinder-Extension für Visual Studio Code programmiert.
Ich hab das Video schon gesehen, aber ich fand die Idee geil.
Helped you to initialize my dangling pointer of pains, champ.
Und jetzt kommt absolut, absolut ungeskriptete Antwort.
Erstmal gleich weg swipen.
Ja.
You just feel like you're not really vibing with them, you know?
There's this button up here to unmatch.
Bam.
Mina.
Dismissed.
Me and Mina, we're done.
Alright, we can keep swiping.
Okay, so we got Tori here with just a disgusting theme, no thank you.
Ja, das seh ich auch so. Also, wenn das Farbschema schon nicht, also Light-Theme, das kann ja schon mal gar nichts werden.
Class-based fun pineapple, anyone want to influence my abstract class?
I'll be happy.
Code Java.
What more can you ask for?
Das sind solche pains-champ-Dinger hier.
Meh.
Interesting theme as well, but it is React-Code.
Ja gut, React, da muss er, da muss er ja jetzt drauf, muss er ja like drücken.
Hm.
I think I'm gonna have to give this a like.
Man darf halt nicht vergessen, das ist halt alles gefaked, ne?
Letztendlich sind das alles Demo-Profile und er weiß genau, was kommt.
Aber er bringt's gut rüber.
I'm a fan of this stuff.
die themen aber vielleicht können wir das überwinden lassen, geben wir es ein like und oh, wir haben noch ein anderes match
mit lauren die hat die hat die hat auch nur drauf gewartet dass jetzt einer drauf klickt okay okay
okay also das war das ist eine reaktorin lass uns ihre karte holen, okay, ich habe einen guten, ich habe einen guten
was, oh, okay, möchtet ihr das, na ja, vielleicht bist du tatsächlich, bist du ein Mann, der mich wirklich zurückrufen wird,
okay, Leute, sind Sie, wir sind gut, wir gehen hier für den Haken, okay,
das ist der richtige Haken, das ist eine fette Scheibe, ich musste meine Abhängigkeiten machen, oh,
also man muss man musste im echten strang credits geben für dass das dass das ist einfach
eins zu eins gescriptet ist und er genau weiß was kommt bringt das echt gut rüber so als
wäre es gerade echt live und es geht um was er
nummer liegt
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Die Idee finde ich gut, die Idee finde ich gut.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich sich ernsthaft etablieren wird.
Ja, aber die Idee ist gut.
Wow!
Easy clap.
Echt?
Man muss das machen.
Ist das Policy bei Apple?
Man muss Apple Sign-In unterstützen, wenn man Login unterstützt?
Oh Gott, fail.
Apple Login.
Ich brauche, dass du mit GitHub loggen musst, weil GitHub alle Informationen hat.
Das ist nur für die Apple Testers.
Aber anyway, wir drücken das.
Wir signen ein.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und bam, wir sind da.
Also, du weißt, das gleiche Verhalten wie vorher.
Du weißt, es ist Tinder.
Du swipest nach links und rechts.
Klickst die Knöpfe.
Du hast das alles runter.
Messen ist hier.
Right.
And then over here we got our profile.
And one thing about this is, if we add the profile, there's a little button down here.
It says notify me for notifications.
I actually probably should have this checked by default.
Hmm.
But it's gonna actually send you push notifications when you get matches.
Unter der Haube ist das garantiert irgendeine Elektron-App oder sowas.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, da steht ja so auf React, irgendeine React-Native-App vielleicht.
The only other thing I'll say is this defaults to solarized dark, which looks pretty hot in my opinion.
Solarized dark, exquisite.
But do note, I didn't really like make them all look good.
Like I just like kind of grab the color values from VS Code.
So some of them are like a little bit jank, you know, like, like, you know, you tell me if you like it or not.
Well, you don't have to tell me.
You can, you know, if you don't like it, you can just go to GitHub.
That's the other thing I should mention.
All this code is on GitHub.
You can check it out.
You don't like any of it.
Go make a PR.
Okay.
Allein schon, allein schon, wenn das noch nicht gereicht hat, wer noch nicht davon überzeugt ist, dass das halt Setup war.
Die App war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht released.
Aber er bringt es halt echt gut rüber.
But I mean, that's my own fault, right?
But it looks hot in solarized dark.
Excellent.
Anyway, that is the app.
It's the same, but better.
Oh, sometimes the code is a little bit small on the phone.
So there's a little magnifying glass here you can do and pinch to zoom.
If you need to.
So have fun, match people.
Lastly, I'd like to thank Dimitri for suggesting.
Hey, wenn ich ja, wenn ich ja mein GitHub Login hier im Stream eingeben würde, dann würde ich mich jetzt einfach mal registrieren und gucken, was so drin ist.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Was kann man so zu angucken?
Ich krieg langsam Hunger.
Wie lange bin ich schon on?
Erst zwei Stunden.
Ich hab schon Hunger.
Was da los?
Gar nichts.
Doch, doch, da ist auf jeden Fall was los.
Ich meine, das Video allein hat schon 140.000.
1000 Aufrufe.
Das haben garantiert Leute erzählt, dass man da jetzt irgendwelche hotten Programmier-Mädels findet.
Die Chancen würde ich jetzt nicht so hoch ausrechnen.
Das Bad Company 3 Video wäre nice.
Okay, gucken wir uns das an.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich eh nur Fake, ne?
Also, G-Bait.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass es in Bad Company 3 League gegeben hat in letzter Zeit.
Put AI in anything.
Ein bisschen Neues ist in der nächsten Battlefield-Game vorgekommen.
Aber ist das nächste Battlefield nicht eh schon confirmed?
Battlefield 6?
Man sieht halt, dass sie das mit Battlefield 5 eiskalt erwischt hat, ne?
Weil die nix so wirklich in der Pipeline hatten zum Präsentieren und alles.
Die haben halt echt damit gerechnet, dass Battlefield 5 so ein Ding ist, was die vier Jahre,
vier, fünf Jahre Service-Gamen.
Nur hat das nicht so gut funktioniert.
Aber wenn man den Leuten schon vor Release sagt, sie sollen es nicht kaufen,
dann sind sie halt selber dran schuld, ja.
You can select Battlefield Bad Company 3 in den Streamlabs...
Moment, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Das ist doch...
Das ist doch kein, kein League, Alter.
Das hat irgendeinen Streamlabs-Typ da eingebaut.
Vor allem als hätte...
Streamlabs irgendeinen Einblick da rein, was DICE macht oder als würde DICE in irgendeiner
Art und Weise Streamlabs einweihen.
Also, dass ein Anbieter für Livestreaming-Tools den Game-Namen einfügt, das ist nix, was
man vor Release in irgendeiner Art und Weise da großartig Jahre vorher testen muss, ja.
Naja.
Ja.
Ja, wenn schon arbeiten die mit Twitch zusammen, aber nicht mit einem Anbieter für Streaming-Tools.
jetzt so lange
vor Release
die werden dir im Leben nicht erzählen
so heißt das nächste Battlefield
und sonst was, garantiert nicht, es sei denn
die sind eh schon seit ein paar Jahren mit denen ganz
dicke, weil es gibt ja ein paar
von den
größeren Battlefield Influencer Dudes
die wissen ja auch immer im Vorfeld was
Sache ist, lange bevor
das offiziell rauskommt
deswegen ist es teilweise
auch ein bisschen lächerlich, wenn du dann große Channels
siehst, die eh schon
wissen was kommt, die dann irgendwelche Spekulations
Videos machen oder dann
erzählen, nein diese
Gerüchte stimmen nicht
obwohl sie genau wissen, dass sie stimmen und so
aber gut, musst halt sehen wo du bleibst
Ich hoffe ja mal
dass wenn
die wirklich ein neues Battlefield mal rausbringen
was was taugt, dass dann auch
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
wie auch immer sie es machen, vielleicht
ein bisschen Streaming Integration drin ist
es wäre schon cool, weil
man sieht aktuell, dass halt Battlefield
auf Twitch spielt überhaupt keine
Rolle
man könnte sicherlich ein paar ganz
coole Sachen machen
wann soll das rauskommen, ja frühest nächstes
Jahr und wann wahrscheinlich Ende nächsten Jahres
da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf
Benni Vogel
kein Bad Company 3. Das wurde ja
vor ein paar Jahren schon geleakt von dem einen Typ,
der recht zuverlässig war, immer,
was das angeht.
Und dann hieß es irgendwann auch, es wurde angeblich
intern entwickelt und wieder eingestellt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Bad Company 3 gibt.
Bad Company 2 ist auch mittlerweile
schon zu alt. Viele Leute heute kennen Bad Company
gar nicht mehr. Also,
Battlefield 6 wird sich auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal
auf Initial,
allein schon vom Namen her, besser verkaufen als Bad Company 3.
Ja, das haben sie auch schon gesagt.
Das haben sie auch schon gesagt.
Ich hoffe ja mal, die kriegen das
wirklich hin, 2021.
Ha, lol.
Ja gut, jetzt erzählt er nur noch
im Kreis irgendwas,
das hat mit Bad Company 3 gar nichts zu tun.
Aber was halt
mit...
Mega geil wäre an einem Bad Company 3,
wenn es halt ein Bad Company 3 wäre,
im Geiste von Bad Company 2,
dann wäre endlich mal wieder
Rush First Class Spielmodus.
Ja, das haben sie erzählt.
Sie haben erzählt, die Karten werden noch
größer, es gibt noch mehr Spieler und Gedöns.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das ist,
was ich mir wirklich wünschen würde für das nächste
Battlefield. Ganz ehrlich, was ich mir wünschen
würde, wäre ein wirklich
solides Battlefield,
die müssen aus meiner Sicht gar nicht
das Rad neu erfinden, sondern einfach
es gut umsetzen.
Das würde mir schon reichen.
Maybe the two are connected.
If DICE do go back to the
Bad Company Games, I think we can expect
to have a wonderful single player campaign
as well. Although the main
focus in today's gaming world is
online multiplayer, crossplay
and a live service. Ja, ich könnte mir durchaus
vorstellen, dass Battlefield 6 gar keine Kampagne
hat. Jetzt ohne Mist,
das war zwar immer, haben sie immer riesen angepriesen,
aber Black Ops hat's,
ne nicht Black Ops, doch
das letzte Black Ops hat's auch vorgemacht.
Muss nicht unbedingt
Kampagne sein.
Ja,
BF3 Remastered, da ist auch rumgegeistert,
aber da muss ich euch ehrlich sagen,
was willst du da groß remastern? Das ist noch
top in Ordnung, das Spiel hat noch keiner mehr.
... and see the seemingly expendable
B Company fight against all odds
in some of the trickiest terrain on the
planet. It could be very interesting.
Maybe Bad Company 3
will be a spin-off game, just for the console.
Ne, ich hab auch so meine Zweifel, ob die ein gutes Game
hinbekommen. Or it could just be a remake
of another game, or even just a
placeholder name, as we await
news on the next Battlefield. Und hoffentlich
fangen sie mich wieder mit so einem Scheiß an, wie wir
brauchen ein Battle Royale oder sowas.
Battlefield ist schon genug
...
Battlefield, ja, also
das braucht kein Battle Royale
oder sonst was, das ist schon für sich
ein Zug, ja.
Über einen Firestorm spielt ja nun wirklich auch
kein Mensch mehr.
Battle Royale ist doch schon wieder
tot, also wenn ich auf die meistgeschauten Spiele
auf Twitch gucke, ist das alles andere als tot.
Battlefield Auto Chess!
Wie würde das denn aussehen in Battlefield Auto Chess?
In the next video.
Ich versuch mir gerade wirklich vorzustellen,
wie ein Battlefield Auto Battler
aussehen würde.
Commander, ja, ist, ach,
das wär mir jetzt persönlich nicht
so wichtig. Ich fänd
ja, nices
Infanterie-Gameplay auf jetzt nicht.
So Riesenkarten,
die sich gut in Rush spielen lassen,
gut, ja, mal schauen.
Mit den Kampagnen-Charts, die kämpfen
halt für dich. Hey!
Das wär doch was! Man könnte so einen Pokémon,
Style Battlefield machen. So Train
Your Soldier. Du, du, du,
das ist quasi so, so ein RPG.
So, so, so, so,
du kannst quasi so eine,
äh, irgendeinen Bot ausbilden,
der für dich spielt.
Gab's das nicht mal bei irgendeinem Need for Speed?
Gab's nicht mal bei irgendeinem Need for Speed
so einen, so einen, äh,
AI-Driver, den man ausbilden konnte, was er als
super krasses Feature verkauft haben?
Ein Boomer-Shooter.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Video jetzt gucken will. Leute, ich hab mega
Hunger. Ich bin grade am überlegen, ob ich jetzt schon, schon
Schluss machen und was esse.
Ich hab Hunger as fuck, ey.
Ich glaub,
ich mach jetzt schon Schluss und mach nachher Steuererklärung.
Ich muss unbedingt Steuererklärung machen.
Und wenn ich wieder stream bis 13, 14,
14 Uhr, 14.30,
dann hab ich wieder keinen Bock, irgendwas zu machen.
Gab's bei Carbon, kann sein.
Kann sein, ja.
Leute, ich mach jetzt Schluss, ich mach nachher Steuererklärung.
Ich ess jetzt was, dann mach ich Steuererklärung.
Ich hab keinen Bock, aber ich muss das machen.
Leute, wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Stream, so.
Bis denn, see you.
Steuererklärung on stream, 0w.
Garantiert nicht.
Bis denn.